welcome ladies and gentlemen to the 2021
fide World Cup presented by chess.com
I'm Grandmaster Daniel narditsky and it
is a pleasure and an honor to be
commentating alongside two absolute
Legends Grandmaster oh you fun and
former world champion of course and
Grandmaster vessel and soap all of
um Yvonne I'll start with you how are
you feeling are you excited for this
tournament and it's a pleasure to be
commentating with you
hi Daniel hi everyone definitely it's a
great pleasure to join the world cup
with a different role I was playing a
couple of times for both the Women's
World Cup well at that time it's still
like the championship and the men's
World Cup and yeah I'm very excited for
this this event in general because we
have some revolutions right so we have
we have more players and the formal is a
little bit different and especially it
happens
uh still under this pandemic I guess
this is one of the biggest events the
biggest and not like the top level but
with the greatest number of participants
so yeah in general I'm looking forward
to it it's great to be part of it
oh thanks Irfan and Vaseline you
basically need no introduction it's it's
a great honor uh how are you feeling and
uh you'll definitely be bringing some
fascinating perspectives to this
tournament
hi Daniel
um you know it's first I obviously I've
been invited to World Cup uh so I
declined and but anyway I would be
following uh so now it's uh I'm
super excited because I I'll be
following but at the same time as a
commentator I think it's uh it's it will
be very interesting because it's a
different perspective uh and I would say
you know World Cup it's the the format
of course it's not a perfect one it has
many uh drawbacks but I also like it
because there are some very clear
advantages in the World Cup because one
thing I like is that as long as you play
you can win
for example and in other in a round
robin uh especially if you start badly
uh chances to win and to you know to
advance uh to play for the world title
of course uh almost impossible uh not
existing but as long as you play in the
World Cup of course you can still win
and become a champion so that's what I
like so all all games are potentially
important
that's uh that's a really interesting
perspective excellent and we'll
definitely talk about all of these
really fascinating matchups we've got
some close first round matchups some
distant ones but first let's have a
quick look at the format it's a pretty
you know it's not a novel format but
it's important that everybody knows
what's going on here uh there's a lot of
moving Parts the feeder World Cup of
course uh as vessel and it is a knockout
tournament there will only be one winner
it's a knockout tournament eight rounds
will determine the fide world champion
in the top two finishers top two
finishers qualify for the next
candidates tournament leading to the
world championships the two finalists
are both in the candidates players are
paired against each other in two game
matches one game with each color so
there are two games of classical chess
uh between all of the matchups in round
one there will be 78 games now if those
two games uh produce a result of one one
then there is a day of tiebreaker so
then those two players play a tiebreaker
a rapid and Blitz tiebreaker if
necessary to determine the winner of
each match of the time control is
standard there's 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and 30 minutes done in
depth after move 40 with a 30 second
increment
uh from move one and we will be
reminding you of the format uh as the
day goes along so don't worry if you
didn't take everything in now the most
interesting slide is of course the
prizes uh and the number of players uh
if on the prizes are absolutely
mouth-watering and I want to ask both of
you about your perspective the prizes
factor in do you think are the players
thinking about them in the back of their
minds
uh well yeah I guess the price is part
of it but I don't think that's the kind
of priority for most of the players I
mean for those who are like top rated
probably they were more hoping to
qualify let's say for candidates or
maybe we determined and for those who
are not in the top of the I mean ratings
probably they were just uh considering
this as an opportunity to practice and
maybe with some surprise that they can
show very good performance I guess but
but still there's prices yeah as you
mentioned I had a look I think it also
increased
I mean to a certain level right
yeah definitely and vessel and you have
a pretty uh pretty unique perspective
you've been you're so experienced what
do you think about the prize do they
make the players nervous uh you were
talking before the broadcast about you
know the first prize just basically
covering the expenses
uh well I I believe for for top top
players who really and some of the young
guys who really want to fight for World
title I don't think the prices matter
that much but obviously for probably for
more than a half of the players of
course they do of course they do
especially if you fly from uh uh from a
different continent it's not so easy to
reach Sochi and then of course you have
to cut all the expenses and PCR tests
and and if one has a certain fairly uh
good chance to to lose in the first
rounds then of course prices matter of
course
yeah that makes a lot of sense and once
again we'll be reminding everybody about
about the format and about the prizes
and uh for now we will be refilling our
coffees because when we return from our
next quick break the feed a World Cup
will kick off with round one we'll be
delving into all of the fascinating
matches we've got so many Legends
participating but we will be right back
after a short break buckle your seat
belts we'll be back with a few day World
Cup round one coming right up
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2021 fide World Cup
round one presented by chess.com the
first round matchups are literally about
to kick off in 20 seconds I'm joined by
Grandmaster so you found a vessel in
topolov we will be bringing you this
round vessel in uh the first round
features a lot of very lopsided matchups
you see 2600s playing you know some
2000s 2200s uh are you ever nervous uh
do you think these top players are
nervous about some some sort of a
disaster you know crazy game we've seen
our share of crazy upsets or are they
are they confident what do you think is
going through the players Minds uh well
I I'm actually 100 sure there'll be
surprises and I still remember you know
more than 20 years ago uh my back then
it was uh the first uh knockout Fida
world championship and I was paired to
Jerome Pickett he is a strong
Grandmaster but he is probably the
easiest opponent I could ever get get
because my pre my my result was
something like eight zero with some
draws when I played him before before we
played I mean and then of course still I
got I got knocked out easily so uh you
never know and of course you know uh the
point is that because there are only two
games then for sure there could be many
many uh tie breaks and then of course in
tie breaks ratings are different so uh
many things can can go wrong for uh for
favorite
yeah that that makes sense and you know
in the pandemic there have been a lot of
underrated people International Masters
that you know that plays so incredibly
well and one of those is of course uh
ABI Manu Mishra who just became the
world's youngest Grandmaster beating out
Sergey karyakin you find
um you've been following uh the chest
World you've been in the Chess World you
became a Grandmaster at such a young age
do you have any thoughts about ABI
monumentra and how far he's going to go
we'll be following his first round
matchup against vadur Baba very
carefully
yeah I mean I read the news about to be
honest before he became the youngest
Grandmaster I didn't really I mean
follow his uh let's say games or
whatever so I guess this is a great
opportunity to see how he performed here
this time
and he has just kicked off his game
against
the white pieces in their first round
matchup we have a bagalu buff
o Indian
yeah very very solid positional player
Vista then what about you what do you
think about abime you Mr will he go far
in this world cup uh honestly no idea I
mean I just honestly I just only know
the name haven't seen any single game uh
but of course there's so many young and
promising players that it's just
impossible to to follow them all so well
uh uh I mean job is uh for sure he is
very experienced uh so it's in a way it
depends but but he's also a bit I think
not so stable so uh it will be
interesting to see uh I well I I think
at 12 you're
I mean probably he he's able to pass a
couple of rounds maybe but I don't think
he's uh a serious Contender to uh to to
actually win uh the World Cup let's say
yeah for sure and there's there's a lot
of players who have a first round bye
that's another thing we didn't point out
uh you know as we started is is that
some of the top players including some
amateur Magnus forget his forget his
last name uh not a very memorable name
he has a a bite he's seated directly
into the second round
and uh you know those matchups will be
fascinating as well
and yeah we see sort of a classic BOGO
Indian kind of a queen's Queen's Gambit
structure
looks like maybe white is a little bit
better I don't know what you guys think
about it
yeah it's just a very typical uh Queen's
Gambit structures and uh yeah a bit a
bit of uh uh let's say but it could also
become a Catalan so now white has a
choice uh he can uh if he wants to he
can also feel his his Bishop he can
either go uh E3 or G3 so it's just a
matter of choosing plans
I think G3 and it's responses to Catalan
simply in many ways something like this
yeah it's very typical so that's maybe
not the most uh it's slight Advantage
for white but nothing is wrong with the
black pieces as well
a better version right because in
typical cattle on black unless and it
doesn't want to exchange on D2 I mean as
a main line yeah they've got A5 or maybe
retrieve the bishop so all
maybe that's a point of us in a measure
that white could go for G3 because if
you go E3 that's the main line
yeah right your three castles would be
more traditional Queen's gamma decline
structure so we'll keep an eye on on
this position for sure
um selfishly one uh Grandmaster that I'm
rooting for is uh Alexander and yashuk
who is of course
um former US champion he's been in the
US for for many many years uh he's one
of my former mentors and he has such a
such an incredible pedigree
um now I'm shocked that Alexander is
playing one E4 I I don't think I've ever
seen him play E4 vessel and does that
surprise you he's ownership is such a D4
player absolutely but I I guess he he's
probably had time because uh that's a
good thing about having the the parents
in advance that uh one has a really
unlimited time almost to prepare and
then probably he decided that it was a
good choice to surprise his opponent
with uh playing or maybe he believed
that uh his opponent was very mad very
solid against the D4 and not so good
opening choices against the E4 it
happens a lot I I think it's a good
choice to surprise your opponent it's
one of the most most important things in
a way to if you want to get an advantage
after the opening
she's sort of a sideline right Lopez you
find your your Lopez sort of specialist
what's going on here in this position
can you can you walk us through some of
the typical typical ideas here
yeah it seems like the preparation from
uh I mean from an extender right after
g64 I'm not sure if black is I mean
particularly playing this slide but
seems like against the G6 default could
be a good option right or you could go
see three different coincidentally uh I
think I played quite a few games last
week or 10 days ago in chestercom's uh
women's speech has uh tournament
while my opponents just to play all this
g690 E7 line so yeah I guess D4 here
uh yeah takes takes
and the bridge shopping street 11. yeah
I would just like to mention that now
when we include the the the moves A6 and
Bishop A4 in the beginning now white can
take on the C6 with the Knight and then
uh let's say B takes C6 the other option
that would uh attack the bishop and now
with the inclusion of the pawn A6 and uh
Bishop A4 now white has an extra 10
piece simply
yeah exactly so it makes uh some
difference
yeah very pleasant position here for
white it seems and uh black is thinking
after D4 are there any alternatives you
I mean sometimes there's this trap with
B5 but obviously here it doesn't work
where black takes everything on D4 and
then goes C5 C4 traps the bishop but
obviously The Rook on a trade is going
to be hanging here
exactly yeah
so yeah you know I've I've been also
thinking about this knockout that uh
most of the times in fact I think that
the player who plays with the black
pieces has some Advantage it looks like
it doesn't matter but in fact I would uh
if I could choose I would always take
black because uh uh especially on top
level if what if black wins matches
almost over so so you can even have take
more risk with the black pieces because
even if even loses even losing with the
black in game one match is not
completely over but if you win it's
between 80 and 90 percent chance to pass
to the second round and for white it's
different because if you take too much
risk then of course you're risking to
lose almost to lose the match and if you
play too solidly then still you have to
be solid to survive the second game so I
believe black has a certain Advantage
the the the one who starts with the
black pieces in the first game has an
advantage that's my opinion
do you either have any thoughts on on
whether there are players who
predetermined they sort of pre-decide
that they want to get into all tie
breaks because they believe in their
rapid play or do you is that not a thing
because I've always felt there are
players who seem to play so incredibly
solidly and every round they Advance
through the tie breaks through the rapid
tie breaks
um
oh yeah if you if you have any thoughts
on that whistling well definitely well I
uh for example especially a very clear
example was uh that can it was
candidates tournament when grishuke was
mostly playing for with white pieces uh
for draw and he was playing uh with the
clear idea to to get to uh to tie breaks
and finally he reached the the final of
that tournament when he lost two
girlfriend I think that was 2010 years
ago 2011 and uh it's it uh it was a good
strategy because he almost qualified for
World Championship Match uh so
definitely there are many many players
that are very confident with with their
Blitz skills or rapid skills but uh
myself because I personally I I'm not
that good of course uh I was always
trying to to finish the matches in the
normal time and not only but also if you
win uh in uh in the normal time then of
course you say for you have one extra
free day
right and you need a lot of rest if you
make it through a lot of the rounds uh
you find how much experience do you have
in the World's Cup in general and uh
what if you know if you've played
how has it been for you do you think
it's a particularly unique tournament
uh as we have a look at maybe I'm going
to click click out to the top seeded
game so not secure of very lopsided game
but
what is your experience with nifon
yeah yeah I mean I was just looking at
the previous position it looks very
interesting by the way so back to like
oh yeah
yeah then we we could get back to it
later or whatever uh okay so I went
recently mentioned this extra rest today
actually it recalls I mean to me to
recalls that in the previous World Cup
of world championship we played the tie
breaks actually uh in the in on the same
day let's say after the second game when
it goes to uh one one and then we go to
tie break directly and then the next day
we'll go for the next round so in that
case I guess
um you know avoid the temp toy break
would be even more important even for
those who are very confident for their
Reverend blade skills because when you
play until the very late and you play
next day that stuff only takes a lot of
energies right and for me personally I
do not have any preference for example
for the classical games or for the uh
faster games because uh I mean I thought
on both like happy and do not have a
clear advantage or disadvantage and it
mainly depends on the level of my
opponent and also I think Wesley
mentioned a very interesting point about
this having white or black in the first
game uh yeah I guess this is clearly the
different strategy in the local systems
and to me seems like mainly depends on
the opponent let's say if your opponency
is stronger or much stronger or maybe
you know just around your level or other
ways or the the things could go for the
different ones because I remember one of
my poorest performance in the Women's
World Championship back to 2012 and in
the second in the second round I won my
first game with if not mistaken with
black and that I lost my second game
with white and then it goes to the
hybrid and I think I lost finally I
don't remember in Rapid or maybe
Valencia so you know things could
definitely go for either way there are
many expectations in The Knockout system
but it's very exciting
and I clicked back to that position I I
just didn't register but now I see how
interesting it is this is Grandmaster
Mustafa yomaz from Turkey facing up
against uh International Master uh
noaman Omar
um I played him a couple of years back
he's an international master from the
United Arab Emirates I believe
and wow crazy position here this is sort
of a jababa London
wow where how did this get so crazy
white played Knight G2 now G4 sacking
the pawn to open the G file
uh in the finest traditions of you know
Badu jababa himself I think he would
approve of this
uh Vaseline I'm sure jababa would
probably love to have this position with
white
uh well for sure but uh honestly I don't
think uh it's a very good idea because
uh objectively I believe black should be
completely fine probably better I don't
believe the compensation is enough uh
probably uh what black should do is just
move the king and then change the way
the bishop and then I would probably
either develop my pieces or push the
pawn to C5 with they do to advance even
more and then the queen would be uh
pinned so I think black is completely
fine maybe even better objectively
speaking but over the board things of
course look completely different so but
again position is really really very
interesting so it will it is one game
that uh I think will be uh very sharp
and interesting for sure
foreign
do you agree with that assessment yeah
it the more I look at this the more it
looks very suspicious for white maybe
bodor would prefer his position instead
yeah I mean simple like black has
different ways to either defend or
attack I mean after which
seems very hard how wide to show the I
mean coordinate the pieces and start to
attack along the king side right maybe
it's hoping for E4 sometimes sooner or
later
yeah something like this maybe
yeah
and non-castle I mean
yeah in that case probably White
white would have certain compensation in
development but of course the white the
white knight on E2 I think is uh plays
much worse than uh on on F3 that would
be a better place I would guess but okay
this position now I I believe white has
certain compensation uh but again I'm uh
for slow game if I were white I would be
probably I wouldn't uh risk so quickly
in the opening
um
yeah plus a big obviously big rating
difference here so you know it's always
possible to play positionally I mean
black could even go C5 here immediately
maybe exactly it doesn't seem to me that
there are any serious I mean maybe
Knight F4 and you could you could
manufacture at this point Bishop G7 is a
threat but
but this just but now it just wins uh
already wins the piece after F6 so uh
yeah this is a complete and just G5 or
does that work it looks like 96.
yeah but then Queen takes and queen E7
and what do you think
even then I don't I I'm uh vh7 I bet
even yeah
wow
that's a good that's a good trick that's
nice but it seems like that's all it has
in a classical game in a Blitz game this
would be good but maybe black can start
with C4
at some point and before G5 maybe just
to get the exactly exactly yeah yeah
well if you go uh closely if you look
closely then of course black has always
that I mean if you think black's done it
nothing wrong so uh there shouldn't be
uh
a reason to to be lost you know to be in
trouble so okay of course white has some
tricks but uh again no maybe uh maybe
it's probably just better to to first uh
move the king to h8 and then push the
pawn to C5 uh so so right
I don't know this this just looks I just
think thinks Black's done uh nothing
wrong simply to deserve a quick mate
yeah definitely definitely looks that
way
um I'm just sort of circling around uh
just trying to find interesting
positions you have sort of two older
Grandmasters facing off uh KIRO Gil or
give is is a name that maybe some people
in the chat haven't heard of he's an
incredibly uh
uh incredibly accomplished Grandmaster
vessel and I'm sure you're
um intimately familiar with I think he's
he's from Bulgaria right yeah yeah of
course we've played many many Olympics
uh same team of course uh he's 10 years
older than I'm and uh well I haven't
followed now he plays for Northern
Macedonia uh but I haven't followed his
uh results recently uh honestly uh well
uh uh you know if you see what Gary did
the last two days it shows us that of
course you can learn to play chess but
of course you can also unlearn and so uh
I think uh if we uh look at uh games of
uh Kasparov and my games in the French
league and some of uh the games of all
the generations of course it's very
obvious that the time doesn't favor uh
playing our favor so
um and and this time I think this system
the the formula of the world World Cup
The Knockout formula of course it favors
very much uh young players I believe so
uh for I I mean the blood honestly I
don't know uh how old he is and his uh
where is he from but uh yeah it will be
always already already the position is
quite sharp so this game could also
become very interesting uh and very
quickly and interesting
yeah it's sort of a Stonewall Stonewall
Dutch and you find your G4 in this
position that actually looks quite good
breaking it down there if you have any
thoughts on this I don't think it's a
good idea to take but uh probably just
develop with Knight F6 if I'm not wrong
but uh I don't I don't know honestly I
don't know the theory I think the
developing is better uh but who knows
taking is maybe also possibility somehow
I don't I think the queen is well placed
on G2 and then black has already some
problems to develop uh the bishop so uh
black has to waste time with playing G6
maybe and then develop but I like a bit
more white structure
yeah the same and also I think there's
some quite some similarities between
this one the previous one we're tracking
and white uh black literally just you
know uh without the pawn x file right I
mean the previous position well slow
development of the pawn F7 and here why
I got this three file but uh I mean uh
the development is kind of equal so also
I felt like a white has some initiatives
yeah it's so hard to make a move here I
mean well I could try to give up the G7
fawn
but it was maybe not a bad idea I
wouldn't take yeah taking seems like it
gives like an initiative so but well
it's probably also possible I don't see
anything wrong now but of course it
gives some initiative that's true so
yeah but yeah even if you just develop
like with the bishop or
yeah exactly and then put the Knight
somehow to F3 and Rook G1 looks easy
moves for white and uh black has to be
careful I I don't like black now
yeah I mean I mean I don't think black
is lost but somehow I would prefer white
um
yeah and of course in this kind of
situations uh The Exchange uh it's not a
good very good shouldn't be a very good
idea to exchange the dark Square Bishop
uh from B4 for the night because uh okay
what what that would leave uh is just uh
very weak ducks ducks squares for black
pieces and then the bishop on C8 is
basically uh not so active uh the only
the only advantage of Bishop B4 I see is
this developing move and enables black
to Castle but otherwise the the
strategically it's not a good idea
yeah he's taking a long time here to
think we'll we'll keep an eye on this
position it certainly looks like it
could turn out into a juicy game I want
to talk to to both of you about another
uh Legendary player uh evgeny barev who
now represents Canada but of course
originally from the Soviet Union he's
been uh you know up on top of the world
rankings for many many years he played
with Gary Kasparov many times and it's
great to see him uh to see him
continuing to be active
uh he's facing off against a very
talented Philippine Junior Daniel cuson
who under it was you know 300 points uh
Below in a rating but this is a game
that could definitely be you know match
that could potentially turn out to be an
upset I think Keystone is quite
underrated
and look at the clock it's very
interesting seems like he spent too much
time here I mean right from the opening
yes move five and
I mean this looks like a theoretical
line this queen B3 it's a sideline but
but I've seen it before
yeah
unusual so may
you know like how this young players is
playing in general
yeah yeah my you know my experience
shows that uh at some point uh the the
youth prevails against the experience so
here that's a typical case where I
believe okay three points 300 points
difference is really a lot so obviously
bereave is a a favorite in this mini
match but uh again uh after some time uh
experience doesn't compensate in my
opinion uh the energy and the vicious uh
the the the the the ambition that uh
um
young players have
yeah yeah and I think I've seen his own
in the uh
Junior speed Chess Championship he did
extremely well in the qualifiers one
thing I noticed and you find wrestling I
wonder if you agree with this
observation or not I think the younger
players have started to play a lot more
positionally particularly more
positional openings I mean when I was
you know maybe their age 10 years ago or
so
yes I am getting very old but um they
everybody was playing E4 all the young
players were playing E4 mostly now it
seems like even very young International
Masters Grandmasters are becoming a lot
more Universal in their their opening
choice and their playing Styles less
obvious weaknesses in the end game and
positional play
yeah definitely I thought that's a great
point if we uh I mean compared to our
generation and then most players just
like E4 only or maybe some are different
on me right but nowadays their kind of
universal can play the different lines
and every line that basically analysis
really in depth it's not like okay today
I want to give a try but really rely on
their on their huge um preparation
analysis but maybe that's also because
nowadays they can access all the
information and analytical to a much
easier compared to our generation
so that offers them the advantage and
also the efficiency to uh work if they
want to really to spend time on chess
yeah that's definitely the case I've
clicked to another
perhaps interesting opening that's
become popular recently and another
fascinating player Arvin chitambaram who
is uh very very promising Indian
Talent he has the uh the black pieces
here this is an English line that has
been
pretty frequently actually wait he's
down to Tempo
um generally this position occurs with
with black demo
right but here it's white to move white
gets this extra moving
isn't this just amazing Knight takes E5
now this position always occurs with the
bishop on F1 shouldn't this be good for
white
well definitely it looks it can't be bad
well the only difference is that
sometimes of of course white can place
the queen immediately to G4 and take the
pawn on G7 so that's the only difference
but somehow I think with the bishop on
F1 uh there was uh it's considered good
for black so with the bishop on D2 I I
mean uh I with the bishop already only
two uh White has simply an extra 10 P so
it should be a bit
just better for white I don't know how
much better but I it just can't be bad
to have the bishop on E2 uh there was a
game with the bishop on F1 uh almost
it's I think Magnus played Fabiano
caruana and Isle of Man so it was almost
a false draw somehow uh they This Is How
They it and it happened uh yeah exactly
so after taking I think Queen G4 uh it
could be the difference now which which
the bishop uh on E2 uh prevents but um
but again I don't think it's uh so good
maybe I don't know uh but again
um
that's a difference so Queen D4 and then
uh I think we in the game uh now uh in
the game uh we are looking at uh somehow
uh the the space advantage and the and
the development should give some
Advantage for white in my opinion
because now after taking uh if you go to
A5
then maybe I white can prevent
the castling so Bishop p7 uh is better
probably so now and now I think maybe
bishop A4 followed by long Castle
castling is a is an option and maybe
that's something that happened uh in
that game uh I I and I don't remember
very well but uh well with the bishop uh
uh on on E2 of course white can also
cast alongside which is a bit risky but
he can also Place The Rook to D1 and and
then to try to stop the move D6 so there
are some extra options and of course in
that case white would Castle short but I
don't somehow it looks to me that uh
extra temp is should be very important
yeah
definitely looks like pretty significant
Advantage for the international master
from the Philippines Michael cancio and
it you know what's really funny is the
game underneath it on on chess.com is
same oh wait
it's literally the same opening with but
again with down at the tempo this is uh
Kozak against uh nuin
this is a different game this time
Bishop before
oh okay it makes more sense uh yeah so
now we what black has to do is to get
control over the D4 Square so one of the
plans is to to play D6 and then uh
Bishop
G4 that's one of the plans and then
exchanging uh the bishop for the Knight
and then jump that's uh one of the most
typical plans here and uh what white can
do is to try to play A3 and by
disprovoking uh and I I wouldn't say if
white goes A3 here then taking on C3 is
such a good idea because then the not
only black would lose
the bishop white would have to uh
to Bishops but also the the square on D4
is uh already uh not going to be
controlled uh
and then why it would have
um
some space Advantage because of the
center so I would probably not take if I
were black I would probably go to C5
that's I think there are many games in
this positions when uh let's say Knight
A4 in this kind of position it's a
better way for black to give the bishop
to exchange the bishop to to to leave it
on C5 because uh then still we would
have
and a very good square of D4 for for the
night
so taking on C5 is not a big problem for
black I would say uh something like this
that's what's that's
um
very sound uh position position for
black I would say
solid with some contemplate
yeah maybe just Bishop G4 because a
lighter may be preparing for P4 and they
exchange right
you mean in this position after a three
Bishop C5
for yeah yeah in fact Knight E4 is
probably not a good good move if white
wants to do to play uh 94 first White
should first play B4 uh and then I think
uh and then Knight A4 and there there's
been games in this position and it's
around equal I think
some close position where again black
exchanges uh they're they're positioned
with two knights against two Bishops uh
close positions around equal uh
positional gain
yeah and it's The Bishop's usually on F1
here but because the position is closed
uh it doesn't seem to to Really Matter
uh which is which is always a funny
funny property of such positions so the
games are underway
um some of them are getting really
really interesting and the pace will
definitely be picking up very soon uh
but we will be picking up our coffee
cups and refilling it we'll go on a
short break first break of the day when
we return the feed day Worlds Cup
presented by chess.com returns we will
be right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2021 fide Worlds Cup
presented by chess.com the games have
gotten underway
um some of the games are entering the
middle game stage and one of those games
features uh the crowd favorite in an
international Master currently but of
course Grandmaster elect uh ABI Manu
Mishra who is facing off against the
legend badur jababa uh and
I'm pretty sure that I I had a feeling
that Mishra was was black but now
apparently I guess he's white
oh that's weird
I guess Mrs White
well that changes that changes a lot of
questions
yeah that's it was I am I crazy because
I felt like we were almost analyzing if
badur was playing at the small Advantage
but I guess I guess I misread it so it
seems like White's got maybe a tiny Edge
but I'm not sure what to make of this
position
uh honestly you know uh it looks like
um like okay white white has this Knight
on E5 which is it looks uh uh very
active but the same time I just don't
see a big plan for white because the
combination of uh Knight plus a bishop
gives in a way for me gives some extra
options for black and somehow I see
Black's plan what he can do is close
Advance his Pawn to C4 and then start
pushing uh his pawns on uh the queen
side and for white okay it's without uh
without somehow F4 I don't think it's
it's uh possible to create any attack so
I I mean if I were black I I if I were
playing I would take black here not
because his black is better maybe but
somehow for me it's clearer I see the
the plan for black and I don't know what
what white should do
but and what is Black's typical Planet
as I said I would Advance uh well
there's several options I would Advance
my my pawns on the queen side and Chase
the knights from C3 and then just uh
push C4 B5 B4 and that's uh something
very easy to see but and that's I I I
see I understand uh this plan and again
I don't see White's plan this is uh uh
but but again I don't think white should
be worse uh maybe it's just wait but uh
it looks like the Knight on E5 is active
but at the same time I don't think it
matters that much
um
yeah because there are already some
exchange yeah sorry but just like maybe
B3 for a white I mean it's also not so
clear what's next for black looks like
well uh of course but even B3 B5 doesn't
change much anyway
um
C4
yeah
so that that's the plan I believe and
the other option I believe is that what
black can do is to play Knight E4 and
after exchanging uh then uh still that
would not be possible you know to to
take the pawn on C5 because the queen is
pinned and then next I take on D4 so I
don't think black has problems but maybe
uh it's just a question I don't think
white is worse but again uh somehow it's
easier to play for black that's my
opinion because again I I prefer to have
the bishop end at night rather than two
knights it's mob flexible somehow in my
opinion
yeah those are great points and I think
a lot of people when they look at this
position including me I sort of spot the
Knight on E5 and when you have a night
like that that's supported by a pawn you
automatically think that maybe White's
got a slightly more pleasant position
but you know that can be overrated and
you know after if 94 is played then
black will eventually threaten F6 that
night's not dominating over the position
so I was thinking maybe what should go
have three but yeah again B5 no that
would matter but of course in this case
taking exchanging the pawn to default
would be a big mistake so if the if the
pawn on on D4 we exchange for uh if
black takes see that that of course that
would be a very solid and easy Advantage
for white uh maybe long-term Advantage
when you advance on uh W on the E file
both with the pawns or uh not exchanged
on default that changes completely but
yeah but you're right F3 is a good move
uh I think because uh it stops forever
the the you know and sometimes white can
even play E4 so it makes sense so I
would play now B5 if I were black
uh and just Advance uh my pawns and uh
so the knight from C3 can go to G3 or to
A4 sometimes so again yeah it's probably
equal uh then but even here it's not uh
so clear what exactly white wants to do
I mean the knights from G3 it can be
stopped with the pawn on G6 so it's not
so easy you know to to
um to to decide for plan but I would
even not touch that bone I would just
ignore probably
but again uh simply I prefer black but I
don't think it's because black is really
better objective
but F3 is the normal move here
yeah those are some some great insights
into the position we'll keep an eye on
it and we'll figure out who's playing
white here because it looks like there
might be a a bug that our excellent
production team is working on fixing so
we'll we'll update you very soon uh in
the meantime I'm there's so many
interesting games to to look at and
we'll definitely have a have a look at
the uh the women's section very shortly
as well
uh one game that I wanted to check into
let's see here Cavalia I mean it's it's
almost impossible to to decide
uh on on a matchup we have Alexi Serena
um who is sort of by this point a
household name very very strong Russian
Grandmaster facing off against uh
Nigerian ajubola who is who's playing
white here
kind of an unorthodox position here
Serana has has the black pieces
what's going on here
yeah E5 seems like a very interesting
option
he just played E5 right
yeah he did
so I guess Bishop has to drop back yeah
and now I I believe what black has to
try to do is to provoke the poems from
before moving to B5 but at the same time
sometimes white can also push C5 so uh I
don't know because I was thinking about
move like Knight H6 now which uh for the
moment is not really a threat because uh
uh the you know the Rooks on the 80s uh
not protected for the moment but of
course now again white has the move C5
so it's uh this kind of tricks uh black
has to be always very careful because uh
this the trial structure would favor
white if you exchange the pawn uh c c uh
C4 for the pawn on E5 I I would prefer
white because now uh of course first of
all yeah I just take a pawn now on A5
and that would be too much it's just a
clear pawn it makes no sense for the
moment to to sacrifice this and again
it's not only the Palm but also the
structure looks very good because the a
good Square for the Knight is secured on
C4 and again all the white species are
very active and well placed so that's
something that black has to avoid I
believe so
um so it means that uh what black has to
do is to stop the move
um
C5 to prevent it
mm-hmm
so maybe an alternative in this position
would be maybe B6 yeah B6 followed by
Knight A6 or Knight C6 so B5 for white
is uh not really it's it's never a
threat so uh even even if it attacks the
Knight that would be a positional uh
mistake to play it uh but yeah the pawn
on B4 has to stay there so like just
protecting with the queen Queen on B3 I
would place my queen on B3 and then
um after B6 for example no of course
first castle of course first yeah
for example yeah and now uh well of
course that would be nice if our knight
from D2 was was placed on C3 but that
would be a bit too slow so again I would
just play Queen B3 now probably and uh
and again even even sometimes this moves
like uh Rook C1 and again threatening C5
sometimes it's it's even a pawn
sacrifice uh yeah it will be
um
interesting positional game
yeah definitely sounds like Serana
obviously has the rating Edge he's also
known and as I'm talking about him and
asking you about your experiences I'm
going to click over to the Andrew Tang
game and obviously uh I have to admit to
some commentator bias here uh Andrew of
course is a good friend of mine he's
known as one of the the great bullet
Specialists of the world but he's also a
classical GM of course he's facing off
against Uzbek Alan Java here cindarov
um I guess that's one I'll start with
you Serana is known sort of in uh chest
circles as very very very much a
computer specialist you were around when
computers first started dominating the
opening preparation scene do you kind of
vividly remember when people started
talking about oh because far you know he
prepared this with Fritz too do you
remember like was that a sudden thing
that sort of happened in one tournament
or was it a gradual transition into
certain Grandmasters starting to
experiment with uh the very first chess
chess engines you know I remember uh
late 80s 90s sorry when um I actually we
played some kind of it was an exhibition
match in Leon in Spain it was called
then back then Advanced chess uh so I
guess I played Gary and it was like we
could consult during the whole game uh
uh the the computer engine and it was
very funny actually because uh
[Music]
still computers they were not strong but
still you know uh there was sometimes
showing very quickly the tactics uh and
then uh in more or less uh in the again
late 90s I still remember there was one
game when uh Alexey shirov he completely
crushed after the openings right from
the opening Valley in some sharp
Sicilian and it happened because simply
uh his computer showed some winning move
and it was a very quick victory for him
and that was more you know like the
first moments when I started paying real
attention to uh to computers
um and of course it was growing and
growing and growing so until uh I
believe in
2005 maybe or even maybe 2010 uh
sometimes there were positions where
humans they the strongest Grandmaster in
the world uh could they could still show
uh an idea that computer doesn't see but
of course uh right now it's mostly uh
computers that find the good the good
moves uh
even in the openings almost in any any
any position
but again it uh to your question back to
your questions was
uh late late 90s uh when they started to
improve uh so they never computers never
stopped improving
and I mean you find we we both I guess
are from the same generation and
when we were first playing the world
youth since it was already completely
commonplace to have your laptop and
stuff did you have the same kind of
General experience
yeah it's like a very similar I mean we
kind of grew up already with the laptop
although for me I still remember that
the horse to I mean I I got the laptop
helping chest probably back to the year
of 2005 I guess that's a little bit late
right 2005 if not mistaken yeah uh but
still we say we grow up with this right
so we didn't really experience match
with the adren game or maybe completely
analysis with the human ideas
but I'm just so curious about this
position let's bring back a little bit
is this still something theoretical
right
yeah
there's uh that's you know after D3 and
rookie four then Knight F6 it's it's an
old move because uh uh I think mostly
they play uh here uh I think Queen F5 no
I think that's the move and queen G6
maybe I don't uh I don't remember uh
very well uh I think this is one of the
moves or something like that but Knight
F6 is a move that uh now it's um
in fact this is all Theory when white
goals Rook H4 I think and now Knight D2
and the black CD to go G5 and to try try
to trap the Knight the the white rook
and then if I'm not wrong there was a
game many years ago between Peter's
Fiddler and Mickey Adams and then
swedler won and he improved but that was
long ago so maybe there's some uh
changes so this line I think it doesn't
have the best reputation for black it's
not maybe very bad but uh because they
found better ways to play with the black
pieces so uh for some reason it black
stopped to play it so now I think it's
something like Rook H6 Rook advances to
H6 Knight G4 if I'm not wrong and then
Knight E4 something like this and then
but again I don't really remember so
well now uh and then uh
black takes on H6 white takes on uh so
that's and and it goes on uh but again
there were uh finally for some reason
black stopped playing this but it
doesn't mean it's so bad maybe one one
new move uh could change the evaluation
anyway it was not like big big Advantage
for white even then
so we'll see I don't remember uh all the
very long all the lines but uh it's uh
old alt Theory
foreign
might not be familiar with it he's got
55 minutes and uh yeah I believe that in
fact I believe that uh in the opening uh
black started to play differently and
not to put the queen uh it's you know of
course for those who doesn't know uh the
the idea the idea of placing the pawn to
D3 is because if white goes D4
immediately uh here uh queen queen H4
uh G3 Queen H3 and then Rook E4 and now
Black Goes G5 so with the with the pawn
of D3 white can take the pawn and
without that would be a mistake because
uh queen of Queen F5 attacks both the
the bishop and The Rook so that's the
idea of the move D3 uh it's a bit of
course it's better to to have the pawn
on D4 but we we can't have all so now
Bishop F5 is the main move and uh Queen
H4 uh is the the old Theory Bishop F5 is
now uh considered
uh you know the the most popular move
here so and queen H4 is uh the previous
uh main main mode
so I don't know
maybe yes
maybe there are some new new ideas uh
we'll see
it's interesting how some of these old
lines are they're Revisited Now by you
know Lila and the new stockfish and you
see kind of a lot of old school lines
that were considered totally buried and
now they're revised so you know Leela
shows some some new move in a line that
that has been out of fashion for 25
years is all of a sudden you know
everybody's playing it again yeah
because uh computer
computers they can go really deep and it
makes sense of course they because
things that in the past they they were
considered unclear now they're simply
clear that 100
so you can uh I mean it's practically
possible to as long as you have the
memory to remember all the moves it is
possible to uh you know to remember and
to go deeper and deeper and to duck to
40 moves line if you want to
yeah that's probably a reason that
Marshall came back almost a decade ago
right because Marshall wasn't a favor of
Black's opening choice in some uh
Generations
okay correct me if I'm wrong but I
remember that probably just since 2010 I
mean around that that and then people
started to play martial again or maybe
2014-15
yeah but also you know for example uh
the problem with Marshall is that of
course it's a sharp it is a sharp
opening but sometimes it can be avoided
because white has a tour uh to several
extra ways to avoid it so uh in a way
it's not so practical you have to
remember all these first lines but also
why it has the the choice to go for uh
uh Auntie what what is called
anti-martial uh I believe one of the
important discoveries was when white was
playing uh I actually I was playing it
long when instead of the move C3 uh in
the opening H3 was played and that uh
that was considered a very interesting
way to play for an advantage because now
if white go if Black Goes D6 now then we
get to the main line of this with after
C3 so what black was playing uh started
to play was to First go Bishop B7 you
know and after D3 D6 but then it I think
D5 was discovered and it turned out it's
uh simply good for black and black is
completely fine and and after that uh
this move was it was found as a that it
it gives equality to Black then again uh
I believe Marshall became popular again
wow that's that's such an interesting
narrative
um you know how functions change I'm
going to click back to the uh and by the
way an updated jababa was is indeed
white in that game we won't we don't
necessarily have to look at it again
um but I'm just gonna open this up so we
have this open separately we can go to
it at any moment I wanted to take a
quick look maybe at the uh at the
Women's World Cup and maybe at some of
the top games there and how they're
proceeding so many incredibly
um incredibly strong players in this
section it is an absolutely stacked
group we have uh Carissa Yip Katarina
lagno tons of Grandmasters all across
the board and let's see we can click on
the game of Valentina gunina
uh who is in a lopsided matchup and it
already seems like she's
on the verge of winning her first game
against women's I am uh Jesse February
from from South Africa
yeah something's got been very wrong
with black peace uh Black's play now
because first of all you know the Rook
is placed now on B6 with the idea
normally you places with the g2 either
to defend the pawn on B7 or to play B6
and Bishop B7 but somehow uh because
there are now so many pins on the defile
uh you can't even move your Bishop from
D6 so there's a lot of negative pressure
for black so I would say really black is
a big big trouble sometimes we get these
positions even without the opponent beef
B2 I think uh we have this in uh from
nimso nimsovich there's one line in the
new Switch uh which uh similar position
with the pawn uh on V2 missing and now
with the pawn on B2 it's just a huge
Advantage for white and I don't think
honestly I don't think that this game
will last very long
yeah in fact in basically not moves if
the Rook moves then Rook takes d66 is
possible with B6 then of course at the
very least Knight C6 I mean black is
just totals lose long enough Queen C7
and just Rook FT1 and the game is C5 and
all these jumps with the Knight yeah
probably night moving to E8 is the best
option to defend for the moment but
still uh instead of the queen but again
it looks just really bad
I mean uh it's not clear what is next
for uh I guess F6 should be the next
move but uh it looks really really
dubious what uh black did
yeah still that that's probably the best
move you know anyway uh
yeah that one looks completely lost
um I flipped to the game that you know a
lot of people in the chat of course know
Chu Zhao who is who goes by uh nemsco on
Twitch incredibly popular streamer and
that she's been preparing hard for the
uh for the world's copper opponent in
the first round is by shali who is of
course Grandmaster prognananda's sister
and progress playing uh in in the other
section we'll check out his game as well
um and Chiu is
is playing with the black pieces here
sort of a typical Ry Lopez nothing
nothing to write home about but I'll
definitely be checking into this game uh
as as it heats up because I know that uh
she has a lot of fans in the audience
uh so so this game uh is on our uh on
our radar for sure
but it looks like it's bad for black
yeah it looks better for white
definitely because uh for example uh
White has many many options and then uh
for example B4 with the gift closing uh
uh the you know who's allow Bishop A4
and that's very uh very good place uh
and sometimes D5 followed by C5 so uh it
looks just a very good Spanish for white
to me because after C4 uh is well B4 is
probably a mistake but if instead let's
say black goes
Knight D7 with the idea to place the
Knight on C5 instead of instead of
playing B5 yeah exactly I think I would
take probably now on B5 and now if black
takes then Bishop C4 or Bishop I think
Bishop C4 and taking on H6 is one option
uh but also
if if black takes with the pawn
then
I would go Rook C1 and uh and maybe even
take the pawn second exchange sometimes
and still it's it's a question yeah
because that's also an option uh it's
not necessarily always good but uh and
of course also the pawn on E5 is hanging
so but again even as you you said uh
moving the bishop first and then placing
the pawn to B4 that would be just a very
clear positional Advantage for white so
Black's done something wrong in the
opening but maybe here black got some
idea like C5 main Bishop C2 is yeah
maybe not not now but but even then it
still looks better I would go Rook C1
and then uh consider taking uh but uh it
feels better for white again Rook C1 and
maybe now if you go to C5
either I take no no no no I mean oh 95
yeah I thought you had maybe this idea
but this of course oh that would be just
too much yeah Knight C5 well now I I
would consider taking but even now of
course now it's also possible to to just
to move the bishop and then B4 is uh
coming so looks better better for white
and not only better but I I would say
much better for white uh maybe now it
goes back to A6 and try it out in there
yes but
um maybe maybe bishop D1 is stronger
than Bishop but even taking I think
taking is just a Advantage for a while
because the Knight is uh there are many
options but of course uh uh for the
moment
It looks interesting yeah so Knight A6
now uh but still I mean many many
options this is just passive position
for black I would say uh okay yeah
definitely definitely looks like an
advantage
just because uh this kind of situations
uh if Black's not able to uh to break
through with moves like C6 okay this
porno C7 is uh always uh
a weakness and there are many tricks
like sometimes Knight takes on E5 has to
be considered Queen A7 sometimes is also
an option so white has many options and
black is simply passive I would say
yeah definitely definitely looks like
that
uh we've got yeah a lot of lopsided
matchups
um in in the first matchup of the of the
women's section uh we have Carissa yep
who is of course very very talented
American player she's an I am she's
facing off against uh women's
International master I believe from from
Bangladesh another sort of jababa London
kind of structure
where Carissa has the black piece is H4
that's a typical move in these
structures
and
yeah this looks like a very double-edged
position reminds reminds us of that game
uh where white sacrificed the Jeep on
which we will check into right after
this one
looks like just a very double-edged
position possibly opposite side castling
is what we're going to see here
well or even but I I I would even
consider to play A4 with the white
pieces maybe because uh I somehow I
don't like the idea to to allow to allow
black to to advance to B5 because then
would be uh very easy to play B5 and
Bishop B7 and develop the pieces so I
would consider both A4 because not only
why it goes A4 but sometimes A5 is a
positional idea so uh it's this is
attention I would say uh but yeah I
personally I believe that in this
position the inclusion of the move H4
and H5 favors white a bit maybe but uh
uh but it depends of course because uh
it means always when you have your Pawn
on H5 then of course uh castling is uh
can be dangerous
yeah and uh we we saw them on camera we
see them on camera there
um as Carissa has gotten up to walk
around yeah we'll keep an eye for sure
on how this game is going and on the
other games in the women's section let's
switch back to
uh to the the men's section
and I wanted to track down that that
crazy game that we saw in the jababa
London here uh between I think mustafael
Mas
uh Grandmaster from turkey at the white
bases just give me one moment I'll there
is a lot of games here that I have to
sift through to find one in particular
literally finding a needle in a haystack
we were looking is interesting because
before we went to checking the girls uh
games so we were posting this one the
black is still you know thinking for I
mean making a decision
but I do not have many options other uh
exchange queens or maybe
take on E5 right
yeah taking on E5 and then his white
planning Knight takes E6
yeah it can easily become really uh
crazy if for example if I I don't know
what you think if uh E4 what do you
think about it almost like E4 but then
then of course yeah it can because check
and white can of course take the pawn on
D5 attacking the queen so uh and then
somehow it's not not so easy to find
yeah and now we have also the if you
move the the queen to D6 then uh then
Queen G5 check so it looks like uh very
interesting uh position and I don't know
Knight F6 it's still not over because
the pawn on D4 is also hanging but most
likely Queen G7 I don't know but then I
would certainly just take maybe even on
D5 and run with the king so it can
really get very crazy yeah here so and
then night I mean because because white
has this check very annoying check on uh
on B4 it means that you white has to go
something like Knight D2 but then still
moves like E3 can uh are interesting so
uh
that's only uh I would say uh just looks
interesting uh to me uh
but of course black doesn't have to do
that it's after I mean also option is
simply to to defend upon on to exchange
you know the I I'm not sure if that was
some game between Anand and barreas many
years ago when black took on D2 and play
King F7 and then uh
I uh something like that there was this
kind of structure which should be a bit
better for white of course
but I'm not sure if that was exactly the
position
yeah the time situation is crazy if you
show who is of course the favorite in
this game it's got an hour Less on the
clock and White's got three minutes more
than what he started with so it clearly
seems like a case of of why being
prepared and black not being prepared
uh could be yeah
of course yeah could be
but again uh
still huge rating difference and I think
I'm actually almost certain that online
this Argentinian Grandmaster he's young
I've met him once and he's very good I
think uh Dynamic player he should he's
considering all these uh
all this complications
after taking on A5
because otherwise I would why it should
be a bit better I think
maybe King F7 without King F7 without
taking also it's similar I think
right because then you're threatening a
forecast anyway anyway King D2 King D2
and then sooner or late I would say
black would would have to go to back to
so it doesn't change much
yeah for for sure
um I found finally found a game that I
was talking about
um the game between
and again there is a a bug that we're
experiencing I it's unclear who's white
and who's black but I'm pretty sure
yomaz is white uh even though that's
that's not what it says here
we were looking at the position after 98
Queen D3 black did end up going C5
immediately
DC Bishop C5
castles and black is not going King h8
and he finally does go king h8 after E4
we kind of were discussing this and it
looks like White's gotten some
compensation for that for that product
or something like Bishop G5
looks like I have six is forced and then
maybe bishop H4
not still probably speculative but this
looks interesting
yeah somehow compared to to be looks
better than uh much better than before
because uh not only white I think they
were white was able to Castle but also
uh E4 is the important move I don't like
the Knight almost D7 because the black I
think black had just a natural move
black could just go uh Knight C6 here I
think that looks to me much more natural
uh but of course King h8 should be uh
better probably now but uh Knight C6
looked to me better because then E4
could be met with the move d4 for
example uh I think that should be the
natural uh but but again I would uh I
would first play King h8 uh just to uh
to see what happens uh and now of course
it's uh in the game
my impression is black the Knight on D7
is much not so well placed the natural
play the natural Square should be
knighted on C6
and now uh this position uh
looks like to me Black's got White's got
a good compensation with some options
like also Bishop F4 immediately the
interesting option not not to provoke
not to provoke
[Music]
the move
um F6 but again I like white now
[Music]
the trade my face might be five not sure
but maybe we should be careful with 95
Queen season yeah yeah that's true
it went for 97.
that is true it's a disposition yeah so
King h8
very interesting idea Queen D5 and then
Queen C3 that was probably uh uh what
yeah
but but yeah
this is definitely devastating there's a
lot of dynamic chances but
um we'll definitely be delving into this
game but first we're going to take
another small break
um when we come back round one first
round matchups of the 2021 feet a World
Cups uh are continuing we will continue
monitoring all of the games we will be
right back
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup brought to you by chess.com
and we have so many interesting first
round matchups to examine as the games
are mostly all in in the middle game uh
so we've got we've already got some
winning positions uh the game that we
have on the screen right now is played
between Grandmaster Samuel Sevin who is
sort of a household name by this point
he's super talented young player from
from the US his opponent uh is Suman
subramaniamide Master uh if on another
Ry Lopez you're the sort of In-House Ry
Lopez expert what are your thoughts on
what's going on looks like White's had
some great shape here
uh but it's why to move right I know
why
yeah token B5 so black black to play in
this position
uh wow yeah it's kind of complicated
right and the black Sim so I could
choose between between your V8 or it
takes a knight right
or yeah maybe it's just uh useless
because when you take on B uh B2 I guess
the B file doesn't uh you know making
any sense for black and the black's
position is like positionally worse due
to this Pawn structure and also the
weakness on the king side but maybe it
could hope for some
uh let's say breakthrough counter play
with with the idea
these six and C6 oh well it's hard and
it seems to me maybe white is better
yeah this is this does look good
investment do you agree with that
assessment yeah exactly and that's
personally I just hate this kind of
knights on E7 I mean it's uh
I mean uh it's just a bad place for the
night especially when it's faced to the
pawn on e4 so there are not so many good
uh I mean in some positions of course if
black has time he can place it to G6
that would be perfect but of course that
that can never happen uh so again yeah
it's just a bad structure white has an
advantage I don't know how big but uh
certainly I would take White
very solid Advantage for white
yeah definitely said viennas is the
favorite in this game
uh without a doubt and we will we will
keep an eye on the game as it proceeds
uh just looking around some of the other
interesting matchups there was an
interesting position I saw
uh between two Grandmasters maybe a
little bit less familiar too
uh to people in the chat Robert hungaski
was originally from the US I think Nokia
lives in Argentina but don't quote me on
that he's playing gallimimir ivich I
think from Serbia very another young
talented Grandmaster I mean so many of
these young players who are all capable
of going very far in this tournament and
this was a grunfels that now has has
been spiced up quite a bit like to move
in this position
um I guess vessel and I'll start with
you I I know you must have a good amount
of grunefeld experience can you help us
decipher what's what's going on here
well okay uh as we see for the moment
um black has uh some uh advantage in the
development but uh he's missing a pawn
so it's a question how quickly black
could
um recover this Pawn on C6 and okay
Knight C5 looks like you know the
natural move for example now if white
attacks
um
the queen and provokes taking on on uh
C6 then black intake and then after
Queen takes E5 I think uh let's say the
move Queen h8 is not really so so
dangerous it's only one check so black
can simply develop uh his Bishop to E6
so this looks completely fine for for
white for black I mean sorry uh it means
that uh the only way way for white to
justify to justify the lack of
development uh in this position is to
keep uh for to to try to hang on for the
pawn C6 so there's only one move which I
believe is uh this logical is uh Bishop
B5 so Bishop C4 is the same as in fact
Bishop C4 makes a lot more sense than
the move C4 E4 sorry yeah and then
developing but still it should be good
for black I mean I have the feeling that
for example after taking on C6 now uh
White takes the pawn on E5 and now again
Bishop E6 same problem and you can't
even take uh the bishop because a white
Bishop is attacked because the queen is
lost and again check makes no sense so
it looks like black is okay so again
Bishop uh has to protect the pawn on
um E5 on C6 but my feeling is there
should be something for black uh
but black has to be very quick also
otherwise uh black doesn't white doesn't
need so many moves to you know to
advance so it's really uh interesting
position moves like Bishop A6 look also
interesting like uh but again now E4 is
an option uh so this is a interesting
position I would say yeah here is
foreign
all right here oh yeah of course yeah of
course sorry it's just very obvious that
94 is uh very strong now and if Bishop
A6 if E4 is not a good move it means
that uh White has A4 our taking no
thank you
so here texia 93 King
E28 it should be good
Maybe not maybe Queen A2
yeah is just waiting for black exactly
right only move though otherwise black
is losing
so many maybe maybe first check on A2
and then and then C7 but of course then
I can cover with the knight uh creating
new threads so uh so my impression is uh
black should be completely fine I don't
know if white is black black is better
in this position but uh there's only
only one pawn and uh many things can go
wrong uh and I I'm I mean the thing is
that uh
if white position collapses then you
lose for sure and then uh if if not then
I I believe blackened always has black
would always have some uh counter
chances uh so I don't know if black is
better but looks promising I would say
so it's not so easy to find a move for
black now for white now I mean if if
Bishop B5 is not not such a good move
maybe just Bishop C4 then Knight E2
right okay again yes of course but then
it's completely completely fine for
black of course yeah yeah I think I can
still Castle though right and why
doesn't move just but that's also true
that uh I mean
um that's probably the best uh what's
black and white can do that's maybe the
the best option for white to just
develop a complete complete uh the
development yeah he he does have a lot
more time so uh well we'll see as and he
is a notorious time no Robert he's
always gets into severe temperatures so
this is rare we have a breaking news
update a game that we have not checked
in into yet uh featured an amazing move
this is the matchup between two
Grandmasters pretty evenly matched in
Eon from India against Sebastian Bogner
from Switzerland
and we have a typical iqp isolated Queen
Pond position but anyone is displayed an
incredible move so Bishop C6 Black's got
the blockade on D5 and Knight G6
all right so I guess you've gotta I'll
start with you uh fg6 the idea I assume
is Bishop takes c66 check yeah
to win the bishop on E7 is not protected
but not sure if there is any weakness on
J2 seems like safe
right so this has to be played so that
the bishop is protected but white white
probably isn't going to take on CA maybe
D5 here
oh
yeah that's so hard to calculate
looks bad for black but who knows
so let's say Bishop D7 how is white
specifically going to take some D6
yeah maybe take 76.
yeah this looks rough bishop f8 and
sometimes these positions aren't so bad
but scary right 94 maybe attacking the
game the bishop the night so yeah it
looks dangerous it looks dangerous or
maybe first take in fact I would First
Take on F6 so there's no way to take
with the queen because uh now uh the the
Knight is uh lost and if black takes
with the pawn then I would even consider
Knight D5 maybe or some I don't know but
yeah looks uh it's not necessarily lost
but looks pretty dangerous that is true
uh what about six
yeah yeah of course yeah as I said it's
97.
that yeah
seven Knights E7 yeah so
yeah looks dangerous so but I don't I
don't see a reason why uh in fact black
should take on uh on G6 because if I
just uh play rookie 8
then take and then take with uh the
queen then the problem is for sure D5 no
then this looks bad for a game because
the queen is pinned
um
so it is somehow I don't think it's
possible take first like this it looks
like yeah maybe double pen
so uh yeah Knight G6 looks good but I
don't know if it's over because even uh
sometimes moves like you know uh if we
start the re the first position the
starting position maybe maybe some moves
like Bishop A4 deserve retention or not
or Bishop G2 I don't know I'm so sorry
interrupture vessel and but the black
has taken in gun Rockefeller in this one
okay okay
and and White's thinking we're expecting
I mean D5 does look
looks like very natural move
doesn't look
so what about yeah I don't think it's
possible to take uh I don't it doesn't
work
so maybe we see the position we were
discussing soon here
thanks
and we were looking at D6 bishop f8 and
now Vaseline proposed this month yeah
looks better for white because after
um
after Knight D5
D5 and uh playing yeah yeah but again
take just take on B7 and looks just much
much better for white no simply
trying to collect the pawns and then
Rook rookie seven well there's even the
second basics
yeah
okay seven check rookies yeah yeah there
might be Queen E7 I was looking at a
really cool line oh that's true yeah
take six and if you take on D7 then
black just takes and and yeah
possibility
they have white promotes so Queen black
black Checkmate so white has to watch
the back rank that's the one thing black
I think has yeah
it means that uh we have to wait a bit
maybe just collecting the pawn on A6 and
then pushing A5 looks like very strong
Advanced big Advantage for white no just
take and then yeah
instead of our V8
Rook uh C6 yeah
still I don't believe it honestly uh
even even yeah even here just H3 or just
it's should be winning
I guess in this position no something's
wrong with this what
no it's not wrong but the Rook ending
could be could be okay for black because
we we exchanged
oh
and then you cannot take the bishop
that's a great point
no I I believe that why what white
should do is simply uh play H3
or a five maybe A5 to stop the move well
can we take the poll D6
what the
uh
yeah black is praying but maybe no
specific follow-up yeah but I don't
believe it honestly I was like I would
even consider moves like Rook E6
attacking uh because there are so many
pins it's I don't know it could be
interesting here maybe Works C7 but but
in general yeah it's not so good yeah
maybe but again A5 I don't think is the
best move maybe just H3 is better and
then uh then we forget about all this
stuff so I I mean my impression is in
this position white uh is better but who
knows again
you know this reminds me of the stories
uh my coach my coaches always tell me
these stories like a group of
Grandmasters in the 60s would be
analyzing a crazy position and then
somebody like tigrant Petrosian would
walk their board and just drag the h-man
to H3 and you know they'd all be be
shocked but it would turn out that it
avoided the need for all the
complications so
um so that's just that's what this move
reminds me of now we do have a quick
news alert Valentina gunina uh as
expected has defeated Jesse February
that might be our first decisive game
um I'll find the final position for for
everyone here uh she has defeated South
African women's International Master
Jesse February uh very decisive game uh
and it sort of ended the way that we we
had expected so I'm just trying to find
uh the final position for everybody
not so easy there's so many games
um let's see if I can yeah I mean only a
couple more moves were played since
oh there it is yeah perfect
and uh whoa just
wait a minute
what's going on in this position
um
this doesn't seem to be like the proper
final position
Bishop takes off one I guess maybe took
on the eight first that seems to be a
transmission error because King F1
versus PC exactly yeah but I guess I
guess Valentino
because still like I wouldn't resign
here but especially five
balls
so
in any case Valentina has won
no uh definitely white is winning of
course black would have played uh Momos
but uh it's obvious that after falling
the pawn on B7 uh position should be uh
more or less easily winning for white
yeah
yeah sure so and we thank of course our
production team working so hard behind
the scenes alerting us about decisive
games and interesting games so could not
be possible without them so uh back to
this game
um we will keep an eye on it Bishop yeah
Bishop D7 has been played it's going
along predictable lines
uh but let's maybe have a look at some
of the games we haven't haven't checked
into yet
um I'm we have Benjamin Bach who is sort
of of course a crowd favorite we have
the entertain game
uh let's let's check back quickly into
the entertain game just it's interesting
from a theoretical perspective
um and both both of you you find of us
know we're talking about this position
from different perspectives so we had
Queen f592 and hands are playing Knight
to four
yeah wrestling you had mentioned that G5
was before five was uh there are many
games probably with the move G5 if I'm
not wrong but Knight G4 honestly it's a
move I I don't remember uh let me seeing
so it means that okay the natural yeah
F3 is okay I guess or or
or or 94
94 and if if Bishop goes to E7 F3 now
this could be it makes uh sense I think
also uh I don't see what the difference
is because now of course uh if
um the difference is that uh for example
if black moves to uh E5 then uh looks
very good for white after Rook F4 and
then somehow Queen it's not so easy to
find a move for black but it's also true
that Queen D7 and then Knight G6 uh
traps the the Knight so uh
or he doesn't maybe I just move my
knight to F2
and still it's not clear how you exactly
do yeah
Knight G4 honestly it's a move I I I
don't remember having seen so this is a
completely new position
so why does white player have three and
an intro play Knight E3 and then yeah
but if you look if you look it's in a
way the knight from D5 went to
everything then I went to G4 and now
it's back to uh this right to D5 so I
somehow I don't really what if you uh
you find what what do you think about uh
what is at least
This Night To note is just a dramatic
but uh in the same time let's think
about the worldwide gain here okay night
from B1 to F1 is the is an improvement
but you also awakened your position by
F3 drop to H4 which you also need to go
back
and uh yeah Queen to it I mean I don't
think it's purely a disaster for black
but uh with zacker like I guess why the
earned something
it's got 18 minutes though to Andrew
Andrew playing a bullet speed
predictable
thank you
so Queen G6 he wants to Bishop F5 and
Rook E8 I suppose yeah maybe he he has
some jumps because for example if white
goes Knight E3 now I think Knight F4 is
possible now and then uh even that even
that's not over because you know Queen
F1 and then still it's not possible I
think to take the pawn because then I
pin but uh I don't know maybe they know
something about this position if he
plays so quickly maybe he knows
something very concrete uh but okay as a
again Knight E3 looks like a normal move
to me now I'm trying to uh exchange the
night
ah then no okay uh probably then simply
Rook E8 makes sense
yeah maybe yeah rookie four yeah again
it's The Rook is not so badly placed on
H4
right it can swing at any moment
looks to me as a pawn extra Pawn for
white it's not no it doesn't look to me
black has uh big compensation but
because Bishop Bishop H G3 doesn't you
think be fun you think it works Bishop I
don't think it works uh Bishop G3 after
Knight E3
maybe Channel History first and then
Bishop ah of course yeah of course that
is true that is true oh yeah it takes
takes and Bishop G3 here of course
and then what black wins yeah that is
true
here uh yeah I was flirting with some
crazy moves in this position but yeah
maybe you can move the Rook but yeah
this is not this is not what white is
looking for although maybe rookie four
and then somehow use the G file to your
advantage
well yeah it is not completely uh
because uh one check and Bishop F5 runs
to Rook G1 no I mean Bishop D6 back or
to C7 and then Bishop F5 Rook G1 so it
and then again why it goes like this and
next move is uh Bishop D4 so uh and then
not so many in fact why there are no no
places for for the queen because Queen
first
yeah ah you take now yeah but then your
own takes but then Pawn takes no so and
sorry I thought Queen can goes to E6 no
but okay Queen F6 Queen F6 though maybe
D4 maybe Queen G4 or maybe or maybe
bishop uh G5 and then push G D4 E5 looks
very good for white but uh
I don't know
yeah
he'll have to make a decision soon we
remind everybody that uh it's 90 minutes
before he moves so why does 20 more
moves to make in 15 minutes that's
pretty acute time pressure there is a 30
second increment but nonetheless we're
definitely going to see some time
screens I wanted to check in briefly at
the highest rated game this round this
is not the highest rated player so Nancy
Europe 2661 we have obviously some guy
named Magnus but they're all seated into
the second round automatically uh
because of this new format sanan is
playing Elmer prudente almost two
thousands
and it looks like predictably White's
doing
well in this position
so yeah I mean you find what you think
about the day Elmer is not doing that
not doing terribly but it does not look
like a good position
yeah because I'm looking at the small
window but the white it's just simply
upon app right
for white not always that easy to count
so many months but yeah white is upon
them yeah I was so sure after I missed
this bishop Home Festival looks like yes
completely
maybe yeah yeah
so let's see how that happens black
black got in trouble that Bishop ooh
H5
yeah this
ah okay so
Knight H6 and now very nice move by
sanon we've got a Knight hanging Bishop
hang and boom Knight takes step seven
uh okay Queen F6 is more interesting try
but Elmer took and
yeah no this I I forgot that what was
the fun idea with a fun app like even
with with equal material what would be
better due to like his positional
control but
yeah I mean
this this looks like a synonym is going
to take this all the way to Victory
um so we'll we'll uh update you as this
game
goes on but we can definitely have a
look at some more interesting positions
one player I wanted to to talk about is
Waldron version
who is a very very young player from
Russia he's currently in a man over 2500
Vaseline have you heard of him and what
do you think of the position he has
against heroda kesco
well I uh yeah of course I've heard I
just didn't know I don't know what his
age is I I know he exists he and it's
funny that they actually uh they have
similar rating and they already paired
uh you know in uh uh in round one
uh so you know the case cookie is also
very I think he's a strong Grand Master
experienced one so uh it will be
interesting to see well I think black
should be kind of fine but uh uh because
uh Queen B1 is Maybe
it's white to move uh sorry then I don't
know to just
maybe 933 I I would even consider
placing the the point right to
even to age five yeah uh it's an
interesting structure you know because
it looks like black is completely fine
H5 was played or uh no that was just me
yeah he's thinking in this position
because okay let's say uh if black goes
um
E4 and then the square F4 would go for
the White Knight for example here no so
but but if white goals plays the Knight
to G3 then E4 uh would be much stronger
so now followed by followed by five and
black has really uh very big space uh
advantage in a way that would compensate
uh the the weaknesses of the F4 Square
so uh yeah
I mean I somehow have the feeling that
black should be okay but of course uh I
don't again I don't know if it's only
okay if it's better or if it should be
okay but it looks like black uh have
good fairly good chances
three sorry maybe but I could try F5
immediately
also in fact it's even stronger of
course yeah
yeah that's a great Point uh you find
there's just no way to stop that for you
right
yeah so maybe why I should be careful
you know how to uh coordinate this
business how to set up
time not so easy to to to really see
what white wants to do now I mean and
sometimes the pawn on H4 can can be uh
become very weak
from breaks through on the center like
C4 but not now maybe in the future
yeah maybe it's time to
okay but uh C4 we have a look
C4 here
can blacks still go F5 but maybe I just
take on D4 it's made I think it's a pawn
or not uh instead like here Edie yeah
like this and then if you take with with
the Knight I just exchange and take
another pawn and then you okay it looks
just
almost a p how does white save the time
yeah but okay but again that Bishop
might get trapped those two problems
because uh
looks not it doesn't look good no so
white white will probably has to wait
yeah but I mean there's so many useful
moves for black and I don't see what
white can do immediately uh maybe a four
sometimes instead of C4 I don't know but
then of course it means you have to take
with the pawn which is not really a good
idea so uh
is because of E4 and also black and go
E4 and maybe Knight F5 yeah I guess the
official F2 is possible because the
Knight hangs after E3 but oh this just
all of this looks pretty bad well I I
meant no not that for maybe a flea but
it doesn't change much in fact it's not
it's not clear what even taking on G4 is
not really a good idea probably so right
uh looks good for black
yeah it definitely does and we'll keep
an eye on this game as Bulldog gets into
time we've got a lot of time pressure
already
um in some of these games we looked at
but uh we will go on a short break
uh when we come back the first round
matchups of the 2021 free day World Cup
uh return and we will bring you all the
time scrams all of the interesting
middle games right after this short
break don't go anywhere
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup presented by chess.com we are
monitoring the games as most of them are
out of the opening and into the middle
game we've already got some time
scrambles we're going to focus for a
little while on on the women's section
and in front of us we got a game between
Penelope drastic and Marie sabaj Marie
is uh is a Grandmaster from France she's
very very strong so much experience uh
and it in her position I mean of course
she's outrating her opponent uh
throughout shall we say drastically
um no no pun intended of course uh
Yvonne have you have you played sabaj I
assume you've played a good amount of
times and is is this does this position
look as convincing as it does to me
yeah I mean we play though quite not
quite sometimes but probably we face
each other back to uh to solve the I'm
not sure six eight or ten but a long
time ago yeah and she she was the one of
the best uh players I mean women's
player in French Clarity and this
position we're having Mary as black
right
Marie is black yes okay
so this this session seems like a
typical self-defense and
wow
here we're basically thinking which
piece to take take back home C3 right so
normally take this pose
I mean do it inclusively to form we take
with seems like B2 points and option
right but then you are losing
opportunity to open up the files by B3 I
guess that's the only disadvantage with
this decision but some country you are
supporting the the four part and open up
the B file with uh A4 or in the future
in the strong Center
and also it feels better after Black's
plays the move C5 looks like because you
have a strong Center so uh I mean I'm
I'm not so familiar with this type of
positions but looks like a white is a
kind of uh okay at least
yeah all right so then do you agree with
that and I think probably objectively
maybe black has white maybe has
insufficient compensation but I've
always struggled in these positions with
black well I I you know I the problem is
okay uh as you see I I believe white has
to take with the pawn with the pawn on
C3 but then of course I'm just
considering them of uh C5 and it's not
so easy to make a decision for black
because uh for example that would that
would be very nice if white is able to
take to jump on D6 you know uh and uh
have a very strong
Pawn on D6 but it's it's a question if
that compensates the two pawns that
white would black would have uh as an
advantage after taking so as we see now
okay let's say uh Bishop moves back to
D5 or to C6 so I'm not completely sure
this is good for white because uh the
pawn is uh blocked and then the only
thing black needs to to do is to cast
alongside and then to the two pawns are
really uh it's too much in my opinion so
uh
optically it looks like black is white
has a strong initiative but uh over the
board uh move by move it's I don't see
what exactly uh White can do after the
move C5 right because it's a very easy
move to play because you just open you
know uh your bishop and and then of
course black can also move the queen and
then Castle but I think it's better to
immediately ask white what to do and if
you don't jump on D6 then of sometimes
so the bishop on G3 is not not so good
and if after C5 for example uh it's also
a question how do you exactly defend the
bishop the Knight on e4 if you move your
queen uh to F4 uh for example then I I
might just take on D4 and then I don't
know about moves like and then check on
A5 that's the problem
and this looks very good so uh
dynamically I I just don't see it looks
like black is fine no because it goes
very quickly and I don't think that two
pounds compensate completely the the
strong bone this the initiative black
white would have on
unless yeah okay uh probably Knight D6
as we said
it's maybe uh the the the option and
then there was a move we missed uh
because it was that after taking and
after taking on G2 then still it's not
over because after Rook attacks yeah
Knight D6 I think yeah 96 takes the
extra G1 and now if you move to D5 then
uh still it's not over because white can
take the pawn on C5 ah and 24. but of
course yeah but even that you know uh
even that Rook C8 first and then the
pawn will fall so I I don't know if it's
really so and then the queen can go to
F6 I don't know not completely sure that
uh
so good for white I mean
uh yeah black should be okay in fact
that was already played the move C5 was
played so uh
in the game I'm just looking at uh the
camera uh from the playing Hall
uh we found uh you think it's uh there's
some tactics
well at least
to roxiator or even Queen C8 I guess so
when you cut when you're able to capture
back the C5 Pawn that you created this
The Fortress along the line squares
seems like the pair Bishop of white
cannot be powerful it's kind of a closed
position so yes black would be very
happy to play this kind of position I
mean at first it seems to me white might
have some chaotic options but when you
have a closer look it just feels like
black is stable and with strong Center
and kind of active pieces somehow unless
you allow white to play some F3 or you
know
files but the F3 honestly I just don't
believe it because black can take is
quickly on on e4 and then after d takes
C5 that's position I mean
yeah Bishop H6 and then black is very
very quick
yeah through the game the move played in
the game by Penelope drastic on D4 and
then Bishop H6 looks very good for black
yeah
just White's position kind of falling
apart here I would prefer because now
white has this queen C3 square and then
it's not so clear so maybe first first
uh Bishop H6 so white has to go to B2
which is uh makes a difference now
because it gives extra check on A5 now
and that makes it's completely different
situation now if if the if the kick is
not on G1 you know
um so Bishop H6 I think looks very good
for black
uh yeah first first uh first play Bishop
H6 and then take on D4 so I don't uh
I know what can white do
definitely definitely looks like Marie
Savage is probably going to going to win
this game
um we want to check in just maybe one or
two more Marquee matchups from from the
uh women's section first of all uh okay
we have Carissa yep's game that we
already checked into previously
and there's one more game we have a
camera four which is uh yukat Arena
italic against anai Ortiz and anai is
women's I am from Ecuador she actually
uh participated in a chess camp that I
taught at a couple of years ago in
Atlanta she's very very strong but the
Katarina italic
um is I think the wife of suwat italic
who's a Grandmaster from Turkey she's
incredibly strong over 2400 and looks
like she's got a very big Advantage here
as she has the white pieces
um
I guess vessel and I'll start with you
you second that observation my wife can
just take on me through this looks
pretty much dominant for white yeah
that's a critical obviously but then I I
expect black to go Queen A8 and then try
try to recover the pawn with uh Rook B8
and uh because the the pawn on B5 it's
also true that
um
okay if white is able to you know to
to keep the pawn will be five days for
sure why it would be close to winning
but uh for example I think Rook 8 Queen
8 F3 is the best and then after Rook B8
A4 looks very good because if white if
black takes then Queen C7 and looks
winning for yeah or white it means that
another move has to be played but so I
just don't feel uh don't see any good
move for black now because even if C6
was played then okay there are moves
like Bishop A3 now looks a big advantage
and even if if white allows black to
take on uh B5 then sometimes A5 is looks
as a better uh better uh but there are
many it's like there should be many many
options like Queen G5 sometimes Bishop
A3 looks much much better for white in
my opinion
definitely definitely if I'm I imagine
you agree with that assessment
yeah I fully agree because this position
could be a kind of dream position you
know why it could help for as you got
this possible and you literally just
have a pull-up and the bishop verse is
nice right so the only thing is we have
we pay attention do not allow the
opportunity to
capture the phone back or maybe F5 you
know create some attacks or counter play
or maybe allow black to play Knight B6
Knight A4 at some moment to try to
create this behind Point A3 and got some
compensation maybe that's one of the
possible way for black to continue the
game
yeah I mean this definitely looks very
convincing for a Katarina and just one
more game we wanted to check into here
is match up between Carissa Yip very
exciting young player from the US and uh
uh Sultana from Bangladesh we had a
jababa London here very sharp position
and
just something feels like it's gone a
little bit wrong
for black here or sorry for white rather
and also the time situation in Chris's
favor
yeah this I mean I don't know you find
if you have any thoughts here
but it maybe Knight ft sign this just
doesn't feel right for white
yeah seems a very passive for whites
yeah as you say they're probably 97
because if black could have the strong
center with the future E5 it's just
become totally hopeless sometimes it
could even sacrifice people well like it
happens very often in Sicilian
variations right and also now this H4 H5
actually in favor of black I guess
because previously mentioned in favor of
white because you have the knights there
and some controls but here the spawn
entry fall just delaysia to Castle short
I guess and also it's hard for white to
cast alone
so I mean this is just a
very hard to recommend any good plans
for white to maintain
yeah
sorry go ahead
yeah obviously yeah the only the only
excuse white for White's play is that
for the moment uh the pawn is attacked
but as uh as you found she said she's
right that uh sometimes this kind of
phones there are sacrificed okay in the
game Queen A5 was played which I believe
it's okay uh okay obviously something
went wrong for for white but uh again
I'm not 100 sure about the white Black's
last move because I think uh 97 was
better or even a move like B3 was
probably better with the idea you know
to to remove the the knight from E5 and
then take the center so Queen A5 is a
bit slow in my opinion because uh Pawn
is probably not that important but uh
but still should be okay for black it
just gives uh I think now the the pawn
on H4 is not hanging and it gives the
option the wide the option to to regroup
with Knight F2 so
maybe I would rather
I don't know may or just Castle I think
but
um
black black should still be okay simply
I believe that there were better moves
yeah one tends to agree a queen on E5
just feels like it's super tied down to
the pond but again I mean we got a lot
of lopsided gains in terms of the clock
like here why it's got 17 minutes we've
seen a lot of games where one side goes
down if you load 20 minutes with with
less than half of the moves until time
control made and uh we'll definitely
follow
um some some of those games and some of
these games let's uh switch back for now
to the open open section
and uh let's let's check back into uh
the game between uh ABI Manu Mishra
and uh we we finally have solved the
mystery of or so I said the Mish no I
don't even I won't even go there the
mystery of uh of who's when who's black
it appears that Vader jababa has the
black pieces and I'm just gonna find
that game here
yes your baba has the black faces
and um
he you know there have been some
developments we felt like white was
slightly better out of the opening then
chapava maybe started out playing him
this is the position on the board
uh vessel now start with you
looks like that plan of B5 before it's
it's still possible Mishra is
going for some play on the king side I
don't know if it if it works what do you
think about this yeah some something's
strange about this this this game
because uh well I I just don't see the
reason why the Knight was misplayed from
a perfect place like F6 to H7 like
fiancatus to H7 almost uh okay uh still
of course it's not over but uh for the
moment
it's true that uh I don't think you can
still push
you can play B5 because For the Moment
The Pawn on C5 is ah it's not in fact
it's not possible to
um to take it but uh but again uh I
believe that there were probably better
ways for black to play maybe still black
is fine but again I just don't like the
Knight on H7 it's a bit too passive in
my opinion but uh it's true that still
of course the the plan has to be the
same to advance to advance the Pawns
uh uh I don't know I mean because now uh
even if you push the opponent to C4 and
to B4 and A5 uh White Knight goes to G3
and sometimes jumps to F to H5 and the
other 25 so
um
it looks very double-edged now somehow I
don't know yes it's not the computer the
computer always think blacks better in
these positions but I don't know white
does have all this King side play and
things can fizzle out for black uh you
find you tend to agree with that that
thought I mean maybe it's a case of the
computer kind of slightly
underestimating the extent of White's
practical Counterpoint
yeah exactly I just feel like there's
the lights were Bishop on C6 is also
kind of bad place because clearly white
people would just stay there forever and
now this bishop you have no active adult
like E8 G6 oh these are not possible so
maybe for white you should switch to the
king side I mean Vaseline just mentioned
this tonight manures uh which is pretty
promising or one of the other possible I
could even
as sometimes goes back to
F3 wider.com G1 wireless.com E1 and try
to create like at some moments push G5
because when you exchange with knights
and Bones this is also a good night
versus bad Bishop I mean if you're on
time to attack the black's King with the
first mover Advantage but the only only
thing we should pay attention is this I
mean potential risks along the lung
diagonals if one day we allow this
bishop join the fight the same would be
completely different
yeah never played DC here even if the
king weren't on H1 I agree with that
just allowing that Bishop to come alive
could be incredibly
um incredibly painful for white
but this this could be promising for for
Mishra and okay the time situation
currently in in Badu's favor but uh but
we'll be keeping an eye on this game as
it heats up we know that uh abhimanyu is
a crowd favorite
uh but okay let's let's have a look at
maybe a couple of the other games
um we got nihal sarin we haven't checked
into yet
and I'm just gonna refresh here because
the the names should update there we go
it looks like he's not in a great
position against uh International master
sigwani
um Vaseline I mean you're a lot more
experience in these positions than than
I am but looks like White's got this
Knight F4 and ig6 idea it's a classic
win hour but black hasn't produced too
much play here
oh
yeah I mean somehow it looks like
something Black's quite passive and
there are many many uh plans for white I
mean one one uh one plan obviously is to
um to place the Knight to G6 uh and
sometimes also of course I think uh
possibilities to
um to play Rook H3 G3 and he's just done
that but but that's but it's also true
it's also true that black is solid
sometimes even uh it's a possibility to
transfer the knight from C6 to F7 and
then to G5 and uh but on on F7 I think
it just uh protects the pawn on
um
on H6 so it's still not so easy to to
break through you know and then if that
happens and sometimes of course black
wants to uh Place uh his Bishop to A4 uh
and to put pressure on the pawn Sito so
it's it looks uh it looks bad for black
but in fact uh I don't know if it's so
clear I mean uh let's say White's
whitesnite can jump to to G6 and that's
probably the best what uh White should
do but then what black has to do is
probably to just ignore and then I don't
know but uh probably if if white is
quick it means it can be simply better
for white because the opening uh should
favor white but uh but again black has
this uh uh content play on uh the the
pawn on C2 is attacked the pawn on A3
attack it's not completely clear maybe
white is again this move I don't know if
it's really a good idea Rook H3 G3
because I don't see what uh why white
wants to achieve with that probably
Knight F4 was better I don't know you
found what do you think about Rook H3 I
don't see uh was it played or yeah it
was played Rook H3 is on the board yeah
it's normal move but uh but if it also
runs to Knight G5 sometimes so I don't
know
yeah it seems like I mean okay maybe you
won't in G1 then you can
H2 but no no no that's not the way I
guess because uh quinoa F2 clearly we
are worried off Knight G5 I thought
that's a very good night to manure and
basically the uh the whole well the hope
for black because if suddenly the piece
goes to E4 then the position is
complete and the main people I could
also think at some moment to
bring the queen back and bring the
bishop to A4
maybe that's the other plan and for
white I just didn't see what's the
Improvement I mean why could comfortably
stay here but
where's the Breakthrough points
yeah it's I mean usually well maybe
Knight F3 Knight F4 work two three
Knight two six but blackened it seems
like like a defend against that kind of
stuff and yeah as you said Yvonne why
does it be so careful about that night
getting to E4
um it looks a bit strange but maybe
placing the king to H2 and then
considering moves like G4 uh makes sense
maybe I don't know uh
and then provoking all the opening
because the bishop on F3 is not really
so good and the only way to activate it
is to to play G4
yeah maybe King G1 teenage two then
Queen B2 look to the f file and then
Queen goes back and prepare for G4 yeah
that's a very good uh but that's too
slow because anyway it's very easy
it's quite diff easy to stop it I mean I
just place my knight on F7 and double on
the G file so just don't think it's
possible uh yeah maybe that's Knight to
G5 comes first also yeah right yeah
somehow The Rook on H3 runs to Knight G5
I don't know so and The Rook on G3 it's
not completely clear what maybe maybe
Rook G3 now so if you go Knight F7 then
Rook G6 and F6 it makes sense
that's a cool idea
that's the only thing that could but
even then it's still not clear what
exactly white wants to do because
uh rookies yeah but it it makes sense
now it makes sense
yeah it looks like black is is cramped
here you find out I was gonna ask have
you faced uh nihal sarin uh at all and
do you have any thoughts on him
we've only played once
it's my impression and I don't think
we've played each other in other events
but that event was kind of uh rapid
so clearly he's a very young talented
strong but I I I I do not know like very
well for example houses style and uh
what is strong point things like that
yeah I mean he's he's definitely one of
the one of the Premier talents in India
there have been so many young
Grandmasters who have been impressive
and most of them are playing here
there's uh pragnananda
there is
um bukesh who is also playing we haven't
looked at his game but we definitely
could could could check in and there's
in Eon who's a little bit older and
funnily enough
um you found weslin in that game between
Indiana and Bogner has reached exactly I
think the position we were discussing in
our analysis with Queen takes B7
and you find you this is the position
where you propose if I'm not mistaken
the movie C6 to try to stabilize
everything
try to keep our A4 on board otherwise it
will be just simple for white with two
plus points
yeah I agree like Rook C6 looks like the
best chance I mean
yeah and then and then we were talking
about A5 or maybe H3 and black
definitely wants to take on D6 here even
if it's even as scary as it is it
doesn't seem like white has black as
much of a choice in the matter
uh but interestingly that you know this
this is just the exact position we were
we're talking about
um let's maybe again I know there's
there's a lot of fans of different
players in the chat so uh we're gonna
we're gonna try to cast our net pretty
wide another game we haven't looked at
yet it's a game that might end pretty
soon I think
um
South African Daniel bearish 2300
against Aryan tari definitely a crowd
favorite
and uh this looks completely dominating
for black unless I'm missing something
major in this position
um
yeah well blacks phone down but that
shouldn't matter that much I mean looks
like
very big domination that's true
um
yeah
so what are the yeah Rook at VA double e
potentially E3
this just like yeah maybe I would just
probably even try to provoke the pawn
white spawn to
to to be free you know so that uh
forever uh moves like c3r uh
uh become possible and then white
um would have uh to to play always uh
all his all the game with the Knight on
eight E1 yeah it looks bad I mean why
why white has to only wait and there are
many ways for black to improve uh his
position
so it looks very good for black close to
winning
yeah and
Arya and of course very very strong he
has that super tournament experience
under his belt I think he just played in
Norway chess he drew Magnus so he's
definitely not someone to sleep on
um I think he's got a chance to I think
they meet somewhere in the second round
maybe or oh third round I think
I think so Magnus has the winner of uh
I think he pretty soon they meet if if
they both win their matches I think they
need some uh I looked at magnus's
bearings and then he made school I think
culottes I don't know if I kaido
I think uh and then or maybe the winner
of culao centari and then and then tari
I think and then voita Sheikh if he wins
and then do both which could be really
interesting if they meet because uh he's
quite talented and young and I think
they work together but of course many
things will happen before that so we
shouldn't Advance too much
that's that's interesting though and we
have a couple of results trickling in we
got Alexi serrana
who as predicted we were looking at this
game earlier
uh the position was unclear but he won
pretty quickly looks like he just broke
through
um against Nigerian uh master ajubola
so that's I think maybe the first
decisive game I see a draw or maybe a
couple of draws a guy magami megarano
mostly the uh the 2G on matchups some of
them have already ended in draws
uh and you know the results are going to
start coming
a lot faster
uh let's have a look real quickly at
let's see here we got Axel Bachmann
there was an interesting end game that I
wanted to ask your opinion on but
hopsinol Turkish young player against
Bobby Chang from Australia
very close rated matchup is this just an
equal end game
do either of you have any thoughts on
Betsy fan I guess start with you what's
White's up two fonts technically but it
doesn't look like black is worse right
interesting one I I don't think black
could be worse at all but the question
is if he's hoping for more is that
possible
because it's very hard to imagine any
development for white and my question is
whether white could face object one no
but in worst case he can go rock D4 of
D1 no but then there's no it'd be two
light captures A4
I don't know maybe I'll pick black but
the question is how to improve
right black can play something neutral
like A5 but
so you are saying you find that Rook D4
there's rookie one
and then yeah
wow and Vaseline you were saying
something
yeah because uh I mean
uh A5 looks a very good move that's true
and then a for uh makes no sense because
then of course G4 uh so yeah it's it's
true it's not not so many useful moves
for white so so I I guess going for that
ending makes sense that uh because
the other option is to play well in fact
we are maybe mistaken because Rook F1 is
an option I mean Knight G1 is next
so uh so it means you can go uh Knight
A3 here but then King B2 so I don't know
what exactly happens uh let's say here
and then you have a choice between check
on E3 immediately or Rook D2 no Rook d2s
but you can see one maybe yeah means
that it means that uh Knight E3 has to
be played but then of course I don't
think white can be worse it's just still
a pawn up so uh I mean it's a rookie one
yeah but still uh it's it's not better
for white I think for black I mean sorry
I should should be around equal maybe uh
so Rook F1 is probably the best option
uh for for why because if if the other
and the other option is to go for the
night ending and to give the pawn
um
something like Rook D4
and then black has the option to repeat
or to go for for the ending which is
still not so clear maybe I don't know uh
yeah
and F4 so oh first C6 and then F4 so I
don't think it's a big problem for white
which Pro it means maybe they should
just repeat moves
yeah and you know there's you you were
talking earlier about this vessel I mean
there's no need to particularly if
you're black to take an insane risks in
the first game although if you if you
win it I mean you're you're basically
through
they exist so it's better to have them
so right black should probably just
repeat I think yeah
you know but still uh I'm just thinking
that after Rook F1 if you go Knight A3
uh in that line maybe we just missed the
move like uh uh King B2
King B2 and now if you take I should
simply go first king B3 and then uh and
then
made to consider uh other moves no so
not so easy your night might be trapped
sometimes even like sometimes Rook C1
can be even a better option than uh so
yeah it it supports it's upon for white
here foreign
yeah yeah yeah of course yeah
but okay
it's fine
that's right yeah
looks like it should fizzle out into a
draw
um and we'll keep an eye on this one uh
but we will only do so after a quick
Break
um you are watching the 2021 fide Worlds
Cup presented by chess.com we're gonna
go on a short break when we come back
some of the time scrambles are underway
we got some results trickling in so
don't go anywhere we will be back after
a short break
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2021 fide Worlds Cup
presented by chess.com uh it's been so
great covering first round matchups so
far we've got so much action ahead of us
and I'm honored to be to be joined today
by two to Absolute Legends and uh Yvonne
wrestling I definitely want to
interrogate the both of you about some
of your stories
um on on playing these knockout
tournaments you have so much experience
if I don't I'll start with you
uh do you have any sort of can you can
you walk us through your general
experience playing in knockout events
what is it like and do you have any uh
any stories off the top of your head
about you know funny stuff that could
end up happening in these very high
pressure knockout tournaments
by 2006 when I was 12 years old and by
the way I just noticed that this year's
World Cup we have the youngest player uh
from India he's also like 12 right okay
but he's participating in open section
that's even with more tense and uh fears
okay so that was my first experience I
was actually quite happy because I
didn't think that I could enter into the
wrong three with the with the rating
around 2002 2003 whatever and then I
played 2008 and uh entering the final
but uh lost the final match and then
goes to 2010 uh where I uh yeah where I
got the title for the first time and
that was like kind of uh very hard to
say
a very tough Journey because I felt like
knockout system compared to the other
formats of the tournament that
contains more unexpected situations like
um
more things that could happen in a
dramatic way and also it tests to the
players uh
energies not only strengths but also
like energies psychological factors
matters a lot and things like that and
also your ability generability apart
from the classical games things like
that yeah and that point later I also
played a couple of World Cup and of
course that's the first story I'm I
thought most of them I I mean my first
few times I just uh I was knocked out in
the first round and later on I went to
the second round but
another single time I could go further
and and I remember once I faced the
aronium in round two and then lost in
some time breaks and he he won that
event I think his second time to with
the World Cup yeah so so that's in
general my long journey in short world
and I believe wesleyan's experience
would be more like exciting and
interesting and
yeah with some more strong fight
well vessel in any like crazy stories
um I mean you're you've had some crazy
experience indeed
well the thing is about knockout is the
difference of course is this more or
less compared to uh to to our round
robins and matches that more or less
second every second day is decisive so
uh and my experience shows that it
doesn't matter how well you prepare it's
you need luck and you have to be
physically fit and of course it's com
it's not possible to prepare for
everything so sooner or late unexpected
situation occurs when let's say your
opponent he surprises you and you have
to uh face uh over the world problems
and it's again totally impossible so uh
uh I I could say that what I did best
was not because I prepared that much but
I prepared mostly physically so I was
physically very fit and then in a very
good mood and that made me advance many
uh rounds so I reached semi-finals uh
and always of course my problem with the
tie breaks I lost most of them if not
all
um
and then
uh
again it doesn't matter how well you pre
how well prepared you are you need luck
at least one day because uh even Anand
when he won this world championships
well it was the first time in 1997 it
was uh not it was not a world
championship but it was called uh
something like Parts uh the qualifier
for to play carpool who was waiting for
the final and then he won all these very
difficult matches but and he played well
but even then he was lucky against
khalifman and then when he won in India
into the in year 2000 he could easily be
out at the very beginning again against
khalifman so and of course but again he
played well but even then you need at
one day you just wake up and you feel
badly and you need like in that day
so
if I may I have sort of a logistical
question but I think a lot of people are
curious about that including me because
I've never played in World Cup of course
how does the flight tickets work like
I assume I heard from somebody that
depending on how strong you are you get
tickets for different days like if you
expect statistically I mean nobody wants
to lose the first round but people get
tickets for the day after the tie breaks
and then you keep moving the flight
ticket is that if you keep winning is
that is that how it works
um I mean either of you could could uh
give me your your experience against
vessel and I'll start with you and you
find you can let us know if you have the
same experience how do you save the most
money on that how does that work oh in
my case I don't remember I don't think I
kind of uh plant when to lose you know
because uh very the very uh you know the
very feeling uh is not really the idea
of when you go to play uh but no I I was
not I was not really uh considering that
you know to about uh money saving and
but but it is true I've heard uh people
consider more or less when they uh they
waste with their chances
and it was not my case but I honestly I
don't remember I was not uh doing the
flight tickets simply
Yvonne what about you
okay so well normally uh uh we have a
we have kind of tradition like which one
they said a ticket but uh when I got
more experienced I I somehow find it
like I could already give a prediction
uh okay so for a woman's uh Championship
I don't remember because that's my last
time I played back to 2012 so that was a
long time ago uh and for World Cup of
open section uh I remember last time I I
just checking the pairings and then I
saw that the SEC if I qualify for the
second round of face level so I just
booked the ticket the day after the tie
break and then I was just to knock on
that day so
so I was just thinking okay if America
could go further I just don't care about
that ticket otherwise I feel like okay
that's probably like uh you know
reasonable
options so I didn't that's what okay so
I thought that's like a typical case and
which I got the impression
it's a win-win because if you lose uh
then you got the tickets for the right
day and if you win well then you've been
Iranian so you set it up so that both
options are resultant success
yeah I don't know if I I choose
something different whether the resort a
little bit different
okay
right the psychological pressure of like
okay you remember when your ticket is I
yeah I remember uh my my friend version
of kobian who was actually playing he
was telling me a story
uh he was playing in a small tournament
uh in the US and he was flying out the
day of the last rounds
and uh he booked his tickets uh you know
like seven hours after the game began he
was playing Irena Crush
and he offered a draw like with the
white pieces uh after like 10 10 moves
but Irena declined it and of erosion I
was there at the tournament I could see
where originally just checking his his
watch all the time he was panicking uh
so my the lesson I learned was like
never get your if possible never get
your flight tickets at the day of the
last round eventually the game lasted
for six hours Murphy's Law inversion the
game ended in a draw anyway and version
missed his flight so uh that's my little
indirect flight story
uh we can check versions position if I
ever find his game and find this game
right now we're looking at um where's in
against the other kesco vessel it looks
like things have gone very much sour for
vrl we were liking Black's position but
something is
something's gone off the rails here
hasn't it yeah absolutely I've been uh
the feeling is uh black misplayed
completely because from what I see that
uh all his pieces uh he's regrouped his
pieces with the idea to attack but I
just don't see uh how he can improve
much because even if he jumps with his
Knight on F3 what can white do is simply
ignore the check and uh and and then of
course strategically he has many
weaknesses and uh in a way I don't think
his pieces are so well placed uh uh I
mean the pawn on e4 is hanging and even
if he advances uh his Pawn to F5 I just
don't think uh don't see how he can uh
improve any further and again
something's wrong went wrong and he gave
all the squares now and I just and again
I just don't see where his attack is now
and wise position uh it looks better for
me now
yeah this is just super juicy we were
discussing these scenarios but
you find any do you use uh take stock in
any of these crazy resources yeah and
this this looks incredibly
incredibly speculative and unsound
yeah I mean why did basically just
achieved the ideal position that he can
hope in the previous one where we were
talking about right because he got all
this The Outpost and even he exchanged
the light Square Bishop because the
black got all his forms on the light
squares if you keep the fish on maybe
he'll have more trousers and also I
thought it's clever that he played uh C4
I mean on time because otherwise maybe
black is hoping one thing it's not
enough three the other thing maybe it's
changed a pair of knives and then try to
capture this H5 oh I mean but it's
clearly too slow right now it's it needs
to deal with
yeah this definitely looks looks like
things have gone off the road one thing
to point out is the time Advantage so
this looks like it might be a time
scramble we'll definitely keep an eye on
it but I know a lot of people are pining
for the mystery game which is heating up
we've got a crazy
crazy developments in that game between
abhimanyu Mishra against father jabala
and these developments I do not believe
are favoring Mishra what has happened
here so basically let me fast forward we
were checking the position here avimanyu
tried to get something going on the king
side
the bottom or B5 there's vesselyn's idea
C4
I'll be mine you're trying to freeze
everything giving of course a very
strong passer which is blockaded but
badur creating the threat of Bishop
takes G4 followed by C3 vessel and I
that looks like a brilliant idea very
bad or like so creative exactly but but
at the same time the reason uh White had
to sacrifice this Pawn was that because
uh not only the pond on G5 on G4 is
attacked but also because black wants to
advance his uh
so that's the reason he blocked
said uh thank you very much for the pawn
even though that opens the G file but
that Bishop on G4 is so nicely anchored
on that on that square very hard for
avimanyu with such a weak King to create
chances in bad words I have not had
enough I'm also going G5
and I have to take G5 has been played
that's the position on the board yeah
because if if Pawn takes then I guess uh
Knight G6 and E5 so it's a good place if
anything uh if anything it looks like
it's black uh
yes probably but still maybe just taking
95 and I think that's like some the pawn
on B5 is also hanging so there's some oh
yeah it's not completely clear
um
yeah
so maybe I don't know if he wants to
take with the Knight I don't believe I I
just don't believe it's it's a good idea
but who knows yeah when when after G5
take like this
and now I guess Queen F4 for example or
some or Knight F5 immediately also
possible so I don't know probably Queen
F4 and then some checks from H6 no I
expect him then of course to take with
the pawn but uh again uh he allowed the
knight from H4 to jump to G6
so
uh right of course Queen F6 is not uh uh
yeah yeah Queen E6 maybe and after 95
like
I don't know if white has any specific
threats I want to play Bishop F5 here
but then Rook F1
and white could triple on that file very
quickly causing problems so maybe some
like very calm move is necessary here
like Rook G7 I don't know
Oreo Cafe first yeah but then then Queen
G2 attacks the pawn on D5 no so I don't
know it's maybe Knight F6 here but then
H3 then H3 it's not so good
and and again always uh yeah
are you on the sacrifice aren't you
I don't know I might just go look at one
maybe or
and then it broke out fade and there's
this Rook of three yeah
interesting position I have to say
uh because uh
it's no but it's also true that uh White
Knight takes G4 is not really so
important simply what I don't like is
that bad Knight jumped to E5
right bad and I became good night
and uh if black is not careful I'll be
mine you'll be wishing good night to
Black's King so
this is a little bit dangerous but we
were with a lot of time though and it
makes sense but it is true it makes
sense to exchange of course the you know
the um
the Queens I don't know if
it favors uh white or black but for
example in the last position I don't
know Rook G7 and then sometimes or
Knight E4 and then oh this has all
happened by the way yeah and now 94 was
about 19 foot and okay take take and
take on G4 it's but then of course black
also can push
so
so this is something like work D5 or C3
immediately and or C3 yeah it's but uh
shouldn't be bad for white somehow it it
looked like black was better now before
but I don't think black is worse now I
mean uh White I don't think white is
worse now in this position particular I
mean Rook endings uh shouldn't
right
I I'm trying to figure out the uh I was
refreshing the board and I couldn't tell
which position they had I actually think
Queen F6 has not been played yet
um the broadcast was just syncing I
think this is the position on board or
deciding where to put the queen queen E6
Queen F6 so a little update there but I
think Queen F6 is quite likely
if we need 695 does look very scary from
a practical point of view
um so yeah this this one is a game to
keep an eye on I wanted to check in
quickly I think a lot of people were
asking uh for us to look at the uh chiu
game and of course you is is a fan
favorite she's the top streamer and uh I
know she's been preparing very
diligently for for the World Cup but her
opponent in the first round is a force
to be reckoned with Frog's sister by
shali
so uh we I shall look at this game when
I find it
uh there it is
okay so let me just refresh
what is going on here
there is something something is I'm
completely Haywire or the broadcast
um okay Rook takes C5 let me just make
sure I'm
it's I guess this is the position on the
board
uh yeah this is that's that was my idea
no uh my suggest suggestion is what
happens in the game you're a C5 I'm
verifying that right now because when I
click refresh I get this position but
something tells me that more moves have
been played
um
but okay for the time being we can
commentate this after d sequin takes C5
you were talking about this this looks
good maybe Rook C1 yeah
looks very good for white but uh but
still
um probably
Knight C8 or something like this
and then
try to block
yeah Queen C7 you want to get the Knight
to D6 something yeah and then F6 Bishop
F7
so it's not uh okay but again now white
has this Rook C6 move which is looks
strong but I don't know if it's really
uh okay yeah
but then maybe
maybe just push or maybe that's nothing
yeah I don't know something like this
that still looks like whites It's gotta
be but but pretty much completely maybe
it was too much uh to sacrifice it
looked good but uh anyway my idea was to
play with Queens on the board and not
without so
um I don't know if if all this was so so
forced
it looks yeah tempting that's strong
yeah for sure and we I know that uh oh
and this is the position on the board I
I apologize for this it's the broadcast
was going a little bit Haywire no it
looks like there have been a lot more
moves and white is about to win so let
me just walk everybody through what
happens
this did not happen I apologize for that
uh two played B4 and immediately C5
the C file got opened Bishop A4 and by
Charlie just started getting her pieces
right into that Queens by 1956 yeah
Queen B6 very convincing nice positional
effort here by Michelle
she went after that oh Bishop B5 here
look at that move
wow ABA six and then two nights are
completely uncapable of stopping that
pawn
trading Rooks
and I think Nemo's about to resign
or wait is there 98
is that a final chance this six this six
96. yeah but then A7 and then uh
me I mean I found that these positions
May sometimes not so easy with the
outside faster but yeah like what if
white didn't have the pawn on B2
even without black spawns maybe it's a
little bit more difficult but here it's
winning
uh you find you I don't know if you've
had some bad experience I've had bad
experiences with these positions night
against like many pawns but
just like swimming
maybe there's some way to promote
without allowing this
uh
like 97 and uh
95 yeah it makes sense so
and then A7 it's Unstoppable yeah that
is true
yeah so Nemo you should be invited to
the World Cup Daniel
I I prefer compensating from a distance
you know you know what they say it's
always easier from the side and I'm so
good at finding opportunities in other
people's games and somehow they all fall
by the wayside when I'm actually at the
board
but uh yeah unfortunately for for Nemo
fans she
will lose her first uh game against my
child but she'll have the white visas
tomorrow
let's drop back to
uh some of the interesting games in the
open section
um yeah I mean Knight F5 it's probably
the best the best option because
um
if uh
if white takes on um D5 D5
then either taking on G3 or or E3
followed by five and then that would be
okay for black I think so hit something
like this take
I think take on E3 and then F5 and then
I just recover my Pawn so it's it's
looks normal for black simply so that
after 93 can we take on e4
oh you're right but then maybe a 5 or 95
anyway so 395 there should be enough um
yeah that is true even that even that's
some kind of compensation but I don't
know uh but maybe maybe the reason was
to take on G3 and and to play a five not
on E3 so yeah it takes and maybe white
wants to take wow I don't know yeah
maybe just to get control of the F4
square but
it looks a bit better for white after F5
and Knight F4
94 take change everything and queen C6
Maybe
yeah complicated but still still yeah
Rook D7 it's not over looks better for
white a bit but maybe not
maybe not yeah Anything could happen
here by the way we have a result Yvonne
cherish who um of course was incredibly
impressive in the latest Croatia in GCT
um in the rapid section he has defeated
an incredibly convincing fashion uh
Sergio Miguel
um from Angola so with the Black Faces
in a king's Indian we didn't look at
this game too carefully but uh but it
was just a very convincing King's Indian
game crashed to the center and in the
final position he's winning that well
actually I went into Rook but it's
Checkmate after the queen moves away so
white must give up the queen and he
resigned
uh there's another result uh that we are
seeing on our camera
am I supposed to recognize either of
these players I I thought that was uh
kovalev but now I'm not so sure in fact
I mean Frank won this game looks like
black one with the with the move like
Rook C3
at the end attacking but honestly I just
don't know who who's uh uh who are the
players
I'm looking at the games and trying to
match this is fun
oh yeah this is uh okay oh my goodness
we had another game that was insane
which we didn't and that was kazubov but
wait a second uh the game between meds
Anderson and Selena Sarah are two grand
Masters it was I I was checking this
game earlier it was just an iqp position
but look what happens 94 black got some
activity Knight takes F2
okay which is a pretty impressive but
typical tactic
so white in desperation King F1 Queen E3
this is crushing but a beautiful finale
Bishop C1 and now Knight G4
oh
very beautiful if you take the queen
then this is checkmate
and now D4
threatening made on H2
different kind of mate
and after rookie D1 get ready
Queen G1
oops
I'm not the only win but beautiful
honestly I don't even know where uh
black is from is Chilean draculate uh
yeah Chile actually I mean there's so
many good players now it's just
impossible to
to follow them all just wow impressive
yeah good game
yeah he he is a very dangerous player he
just played in the US
um and and uh I was familiar with some
of his games very strong attacking
players he defeats very strong Danish
Grandmaster uh Anderson
okay Plato is him I cannot see his name
is is it like a young Chilean Grand uh
International master of great
Grandmaster she's a dream he's a baby in
his I think 20s he's probably my age so
50 yeah just kidding uh 25 or 26 I think
yeah I think we've played a match in
Chile a few years ago like a friendly
one yeah
how did that one go sorry go ahead he
only needs a drone now with the white
pieces so it looks easy but of course uh
it depends I mean for example in Libya
when I was I at some point I had in 10
in 10 games nine nine and a half points
and the reason was that sometimes I was
winning the first game with the black
pieces and be in a normal Tournament of
course uh someone who is rated lower
than me huge he was supposed to be happy
with with a draw but because it was a
knockout they they tried to beat me with
black and that's the reason I I was able
to make so so many uh wins you know
because uh I was white and they were
playing for win with the black pieces so
it depends uh and the only one who
didn't do that was mosesia nahi of a
draw and because he was knocked out
um
uh but it's a for someone who is in good
shape it's a very good uh I would say a
very good uh a position you know to to
score many rating points to win many
rating points and to win many games of
course
yeah no definitely you've got so many
opportunities and the the psychology and
the Dynamics of these matchups is
something that we're going to get into a
lot more but uh
uh we also know that it is very very
late uh for you yifon and uh just wanted
to say
um before I let you uh share share some
of your thoughts how much uh I think I
we appreciate you coming on it it's a
great honor to to have commentated with
you we certainly don't want to keep you
too long but before we uh go on a break
and let you have your well-deserved rest
just wanted to ask you maybe uh what
your general thoughts are on how this
tournament began who maybe some of your
favorites are obviously and and I also
perhaps uh you could share your thoughts
on whether you think Magnus is going to
get get upset or is he just gonna go all
the way and Crush everybody
uh so sorry I didn't get your last
question you just follow up with a few
questions yeah yeah sorry so I guess
just maybe your general thoughts some
people you're you're looking at and
whether you think Magnus is just going
to crush everybody or is he going to get
upset by somebody
okay I thought this is like right there
and I'm very happy to draw it and
drawing with
like this is also a good I mean
opportunity to follow some serious chess
after quite some long time and we face
like
um very uh interesting positions and uh
well so talking about the second
question Magnus yeah to be honest uh I
was a bit surprised when he decided to
play the World Cup a few years ago you
know like uh I don't remember maybe it's
7 2017 or 19 maybe 17 right but he
didn't perform very well in that time
and this time we'll see I mean that
holiday he'll go for the certain rounds
of the list because his friends is there
but when he's facing strong players like
Vaseline mentioned the dupe of maybe one
of the further rounds right and maybe
starting from this point and going
further things are a kind of uh out of
control I guess for anyone because this
is mini matches only two games basically
one mistake or the you know uh brings
you like very hard times to find it back
so it's really hard to say I mean he's
clearly the favorites for most of the
players but for knockout system I guess
this uh level favorite a little bit so
you know reduce the not the same level
as for example rounder Robin Germans or
matches I guess he'll be even stand out
in those type of formats but we'll see
because this time not not only magnets
but other top 10 many of the top 10
players are playing right so I guess one
of the strongest edition of the World
Cup so far recently
mm-hmm well that that makes a lot of
sense uh you find you'll be joining us
for for the later rounds as well uh but
we won't keep you any longer thank you
so much for joining today you find it
it's a great honor and uh we will go on
a short break when we come back more
action from the 21 2021 fide Worlds Cup
presented by chess.com don't go anywhere
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup and of course chess.com will
be your exclusive twitch home for the
video feeds for this year's World Chess
Championship join us for the best
coverage around as we watch this year's
flares the defending Champion Magnus
Carlson Challenger Jan and palmyoshi or
the title The World Chess championships
it's coming in November so mark your
calendars and that will be on chess.com
we have the video feeds the coverage
will be killer the match will be killing
you will definitely not want to miss
that coming your way in November but for
now
uh round one of the World's Cup is
ongoing uh it was excellent it was
awesome to be joined by by ho yifon
uh now I'm stuck with some vessel in you
know I don't know if you're qualified to
commentate on the games or a world
champion Legend ah
just kidding of course
um
the time scrambles are underway vessel
and um what have been your thoughts so
far on this round things going as
expected or
uh or have you been surprised at the way
some of these games have been going
well I mean of course in I would say
General General level is getting better
and better so uh some of the supposedly
weak opponents they are putting up a
solid fight and uh but of course it's
just too early I don't think in fact
um first round matters that much in a
way that uh
the The Logical outcome for most of the
mini matches is that the the big
favorites because they're uh they will
pass to the second round because there
are
um um
big rating differences sometimes and in
I guess in World Cup also in this
especially in this case we have some
external factors like jet lag for
example you know players that arrive
from uh different continents they don't
feel as good as Uh Russian players I I I
I believe so uh for the moment from what
I see there are no no big big surprises
and of course you have such incredibly
Rich World Cup experience do you
remember off the top of your head any
like crazy upsets I think I mentioned
earlier anans lost to someone in the
first round this was many years ago but
is there anything that stands out to you
from from all of your experience
uh well again when I played first this
knockout event it was uh I was
considered one of the Tour all three uh
favorites and together with even took we
lost uh in the first round I lost to uh
your own picket
he loves to say everyone also very
easily I would say but then Las Vegas in
1999 I think uh Nissi piano he knocked
out even took and shirov and there were
several surprises uh but it's also true
that India if you consider uh in in year
2000 then three of the four rating
favorites which is the semi-final and
then in women World Championship then I
think the the top uh the top rated one I
I think maybe it was Susan paulger I
don't remember who she was then so
sometimes it can be you know it's in in
a way it's random it could go
both ways but again Las Vegas was very
surprising and then
and then I think it was uh the very
beginning the in in the Netherlands
Cunningham
in 1997 there were several big surprises
also but India Was unant Won it was not
easy but he won he was rated favorite uh
and then Las Vegas was many many there
were many many surprises
mm-hmm yeah it sounds like it depends
sort of on the tournament sometimes it's
one way sometimes it's another one one
game I've been looking around to see if
there are any games where the lower
rated player is is better and I did find
one where Dimitri sclerov who is
international Master looks like he's
representing Finland is playing besito
or Bailey uh from Azerbaijan very strong
GM over 2600 but I mean if I'm reading
this right
after Knight takes A4 I think blacks
black is pretty much dominating the end
game wrestling definitely yeah because
he can uh I expect white to take the
pawn on uh I the first to check on G4
and then take on uh G7 but looks very
difficult to stop they they Pawn Yeah
but even you know uh okay it's uh less
than 150 points difference more or less
so it's not like 300 no no 500 Point
difference
um but and even if he loses with the
white pieces I think uh it's not
completely over I would say because this
azeri players are there
tend to be very very tricky I think very
um many a lot of talent I would say in
Azerbaijan uh also between the not only
you have uh Mama Jamaica but also
in the past we had gashimov obviously uh
and uh I don't know but again many many
very strong uh uh chesco so it's not
completely or if even if if white loses
here in the first round
first of the mini match
yeah that's that's true we've definitely
seen our share of matches that where
that happened uh another game where we
might see an even bigger upset
take a look at this position now
Gregorio paren who is you know household
name over 2650 is facing off uh Sri
Lankan uh player uh Leonard leonage I
hope I'm pronouncing that halfway
decently and it I think it's a dead draw
so we might see this this might be
numerically one of the bigger offsets of
of game one of course not a disaster but
exactly I mean it matters to who who
goes to the second round it's not about
the way you go so uh when I'm talking
about surprises it's uh not in a single
game but in uh you know in uh
uh in in the round so as long as oparion
wins the mini the match uh that it
doesn't matter how how exactly uh what
the result was I mean
um
so I guess I guess uh but but it is also
through all these unknown players from
India and of course also from China in
this case it's Sri Lanka they're
underrated the young and it's not it's
not so easy to to understand what the
real strength is so it's very easy it
could very easily be someone who plays
uh 100 to 200 points uh better than his
rating
yeah and with with covet and people
playing online the situation got out of
control there were a couple tournaments
in the US over the board tournaments
resumed World open
where you saw in the open section
Grandmasters were in the bottom of the
pack and you had like 2100s
at the top for many rounds they were
just beating up on on these four GMS
because
you know a lot of the a lot of kids with
with reduced School load they just you
know they studied very very diligently
and yeah in some cases as you said 200
300 points are underrated easily exactly
which is kind of crazy
so if you have us better be careful oh
now this this is heated up
well I I mean uh it's it's a mystery how
the poll from C2 uh
let's see
uh it's it's funny to see let's say F4
as I said yeah Rook B1 yeah okay G5 this
still looks amazing for black Aryan play
G well G4 I don't I I don't know well it
makes sense to play G4 because otherwise
I guess what white want wanted to do is
to take and then place the Knight to F4
so it makes sense to uh close it but
then yeah closing I don't know so okay
okay before E3 and now c4 this is this
is the point
so if I think the the diff What probably
uh uh tari missed was that after B4
if Black Goes uh
Bishop B5 then I guess A4
and then A4 yeah and if you take them I
guess and then if you take I take the
pawn on e4 so it's uh
now and the Knight is entering in the in
the pawn on G4 is also hanging but yeah
well
yeah now it's simply not not so clear
anymore and uh final in the position we
with the pawn on C7 of course it's
blocked but
uh well the Knight is still out this
doesn't really change much uh yeah the
Knight is out of the game but maybe
still blackish okay because uh but it's
very strange like Rook C5 maybe but then
where does the bishop I mean Bishop is
attacked so probably maybe A6 yeah it's
still black looks like he's under
control but uh also the Knight can go
somehow to
uh H4 and attack I don't know
it's yeah some things uh changed but it
looks still good somehow for for black
although of course with such a pawn you
never know I mean it could easily be
that why it goes something like Knight
C2 and then uh Knight D4 and who knows
that's yeah this game could turn around
very quickly
yeah
but uh I mean that's I guess that's what
you do if you're if you're under you
know lower rated by 300 points you stick
around and see your channel you know
seize your channel for example for
example now if I just go Knight C2
attacking to take on D4 and if Bishop
goes to takes
Rook D1 and then I don't know if you go
take the take on D4 I don't know and
there are many yep I don't know it looks
like it doesn't it doesn't work now
because of the move now black wins or
but maybe I should no maybe Queen C8
check
yeah
yeah Queen C8 check and King F2 and I I
don't know wow looking up too you're
trying to that's an incredible position
but then still it's Czech it's still
very messy it looks maybe still white
black yeah Shaq maybe Queen is six here
yeah still black wins but uh it's verse
somehow uh it especially if in a time
travel sometimes uh things look
completely different
um yeah that's exactly right the time
pressure is what it means for higher
ratings
I think uh uh another A6 was not played
uh White just took on white seven which
which makes a lot of sense because now
uh also sometimes the pawn on D4 is
attacked at what black can do is uh Rook
A6 and take on A2 I I think that makes
sense no now if you go Queen C5 here
but
but still I mean uh it's black to move
or not after Queen C5 here will be black
to move so Rook C6 was played
oh and then he just wants to see he just
wants to uh collect the pawn
on C7 which is like but then what about
take
and then Knight C2
yeah
if I take with a bishop then
and then and then if you go
um
if you go
if you
yeah the question is how to defend
against this queen D5 idea with
obviously made threats
so maybe Queen E3 but
yeah it's nah that doesn't look good
though I was gonna try to play Queen D5
Queen V3 against Queen D5 oh okay it's
always possible to play something like
H4 and King H2 so it's not immediate
made but Luke is very bad it's true
oh yeah or maybe what black has to White
has to do is to to take and play B5 but
that's only uh for the moment that stops
uh you know just black and just take and
then still the Knight is trapped on E1
okay go back to statistics yeah it
doesn't look so good it's true Rook C6
is a good move so I don't know if the
move uh Queen A7 was that good probably
Rook C5 made more sense
yeah aryan's very very strong in these
positions we do have a very interesting
punt end game uh in the entertain game
which where time control was made
I don't know if it's gonna help White
I mean optically this looks losing for
white exactly right now black is down a
bomb which is really interesting but the
problem is that if white tries to save
the F Pawn black has this move at H5
and after King F16 F5 black spawns are
stopping away from creating a passer is
this just losing or is this white have
some crazy crazy chances here
uh should be losing I I guess I just
don't see uh because uh let's say
uh I think it just lost
so uh I just don't I don't see any
content play because even if you go
something like
uh
H like uh King F3
H5 and then H4 then uh but I can just
take and then should be simply lost
yeah this is a classic example where the
black uses this past fonts to distract
Black's keg and then walks walks the
king so black he has to Simply wait and
then once a whites move over with the
pawns then he has to move his King and
allow the advance of the H Pawn and
sometimes of course also possibilities
to uh no I mean I thought King G2 here
Kim G2 King F6
um King H3 King F5 King H4 and now King
E4 is also a possibility or King D6
looks completely winning both yeah this
might even be more clinical because this
is just eventually you're going to force
white to give up all the Pawns
exactly yeah oh look so
wow
he's he's been an interesting game how
how that happened after
after the opening but uh yeah G5
yeah yeah we had an exchange sack and
then okay we kind of discussed a similar
position in fact uh the default was
probably a mistake no because it looks
really good for white in a way uh let's
say uh here
I don't know but
I would just go Rook F1
and then uh after Bishop I could maybe
remove my queen and then Place uh the
queen to to to The Rook 25 and Advance
slowly looks very good
right complete positional domination
have seven times a week or or even go
something like Bishop D6 threatening uh
Queen C5 or ore5 it looks very good
but he played B4 and he allowed Andrew
to counter sacrifice his exchange back
and Black's fine now yeah shouldn't be
worse for white but somehow cinderov
I mean White's definitely I think not
worse sir but how did this Pawn on game
occur I think okay here here Queen D5
oh Ricky okay probably blunder this this
is a very nice move yes yeah I think you
simply probably believed he was uh close
to equality but now he's just lost
and yeah so what has happened in the
game white is thinking after G5 has made
time control but it's not gonna help
Andrew is most probably going to win
his first game with a black got the huge
result for Andrew Tang
okay so let's have a look at maybe some
of the other games has got a couple of
games that are winding down
um
okay we got the dura Bailey game we took
a look at that we have a game that we
haven't looked at for a while
who play that weird arvind was white so
that was the weird e45 English with an
extra tempo for for white yeah
and looks like White's got these monster
pawns on the king side yeah so it's um
it's very interesting position in fact
uh because okay the bishop on B3 is a
bit misplaced sometimes uh but uh
and of course it's also true that the
pawns there not so not always so easy to
advance so let's say uh let me see
um
I don't know well
yeah
I if what if black just Waits by playing
a move like King G7 yeah that's exactly
what happened yeah because he said we
because G4 can be played now it means
that Queen G3 of course oh yeah Queen G3
is subscribe
and if you take uh still the pawn on C3
is attacked and uh G4 is still not a
possibility so white has to lose another
10p but maybe it's I don't know because
uh well for sure uh black shouldn't be
worse but uh
it's yeah this could go either way it
looks easier to to play with uh white
with black maybe okay Queen here
21.1 Queen H4 is not really a thread
because of Rook h8
I don't for the moment so Queen D2 uh
makes some sense but I would probably
try a move like I don't know if white
wants to to move
the rook and to give some check to E5
but it's also not clear where exactly
white can go with and uh with the Rook
so if white plays B5 I think then Rook
C5 is probably yeah but but even that
even that is some that's only one check
for the moment uh so okay after queening
one uh what if I try to exchange with
Queen D2 still
yeah Queen D2 and again 24 okay shade
doesn't do anything well
now it now it now it's dangerous because
uh also the King on G7 runs to checks so
Queen D2 is uh
uh maybe not so so good but it's not so
easy to find the move and wasting time
for A4 I don't know
B5 could be critical of course white can
wait with the move like play some move
like C6
uh but
with the hard move to plan time pressure
also you feel like you have to do
something and of course there are moves
like rookie 3 so it's not clear if that
changes much now
so right and presumably there's a Time
scramble probably the time the exact
time stamp is
is inaccurate
um but we'll keep an eye on that one now
a lot of people I think want to look at
the uh I want an update on the mystery
game
so let's switch to that one and it looks
like badur is just crushing it here
yeah looks like uh he's put all his
pieces on the winning squares and so
what happens after Knight takes G3 where
exactly is the bishop H3 no oh okay for
the moment I have check on e4 I can take
and give check only for which is not uh
but
what G1
yeah King G1 and then if I take and
maybe just push the pawn to C3 no let's
say oh not immediately not maybe first
check but even that's not you know even
that's not
um
like the end maybe because if I check on
F1 on F5 then the King goes to E1 and
sometimes uh King is even able to stop
the pawn so you mean Knight if you start
for the very beginning Knight G3 let's
see again yeah G3
okay yeah but now some move has to be
found or maybe queen or queen H6 doesn't
seem right
no because why white wants to to take uh
to play Rook G1 also you know yeah
so well that'll be very nice if white
would be able to exchange the black
would be able to exchange the Queens but
uh
these positions can be frustrating
because you wait a minute what if you go
Queenie seven here is that is that no
you just losing ah you mean like 2700 G3
yeah but even Rook have fate it doesn't
like this it's okay yeah because I
thought maybe trade on your own terms
here and if white doesn't do anything
then I just go c3c2
yeah Queens yeah Queen e77 but if it's a
question if it's it's a this move is
easy to find like it's a very good move
you're right there is Knight D7 though
maybe
and and uh
but then maybe I exchanged the Queens no
but still G7 Rook G3 Queen G7 and then I
go to nf6
yeah and and then stop J yeah and then
stop the
then it'd be a draw Maybe yeah this one
I think is a drug because both sides
will have connect protected pastors but
I guess in this position there is some
even like there's probably some but this
is hard to see I mean
we don't know exactly what the time
situation is first I guess we should
wait for Mishra to Knight takes G3 is
not force I guess he's thinking about
Knight F4 as well maybe
doesn't look great but maybe it's a move
not a four queen queen just moves to uh
H6 and I if you take one H5 somehow in a
way
um
white is also paint so it makes no sense
to take the H5 Pawn and if you take it
yeah with the queen is I mean the
exchange of the queen should favor very
much black I think but of course it all
depends of uh some tactics so Knight
yeah Knight G3 so what about what about
uh
so
Bishop H3 stake and queen d8 check so it
doesn't work or in the a check I have to
go Queen E8 okay so what's wrong now
with with uh that Knight on e4 is a
monster it's covering all these checking
squares and F2 as well
no this is losing for white so I guess
in this position
of course of course King King uh I mean
um
Rook G1 is possible but it's it's just
uh I don't know it doesn't look so good
for white then so that's luck as a move
I think this is what he's considering
yeah that definitely is something to
calculate here Knight F4 versus Knights
hp3 but we're expecting he's probably
going to take on G3
[Music]
um
okay so that's that's a game we're gonna
but even I mean I was just uh it was
curious
I don't think it works in fact I had
some idea but I simply think it's just a
bluff uh so
Oh you mean in this in this position
yeah yeah
um
all right so we'll we'll take a look at
that anyway it's it's a critical uh what
about some crazy stuff like
take on G3 let's say
oh but that was okay uh is it is it
winning for black okay you take on H3
take
index yes and then my idea was to go
something like Rook A2 it's totally wow
okay to a knight G3 yeah just do you
have more than Perpetual after King H2
so let's say I got another one king H1
yeah is it more than because white has
this very nasty checks and right also
Queen V8 is still there so I don't know
but probably just nothing I don't know
but it could be a nice try
I mean yeah for sure particularly in
like time pressure it's yeah I would see
a move off the top of my head
for black
exactly because Queen V8 is still there
and the check is very uh annoying so and
of course many there's it's easy to miss
uh yeah here maybe Queen C8 yeah maybe
but then uh let me see
yeah maybe just because
yeah Quincy it looks enough this looks
scary but after King G8 that King hides
under the rook and you know it's not I
don't know ig6 or something like that
but that's nothing yeah I it's difficult
to
should be winning for black because yeah
um now this is winning so somehow
yeah yeah for sure so he's ABI Manu he
did take on P3 and by the way time
control was made so that's that explains
the time that they spent thinking
um and and now butter will probably take
take his time and this is really good
for black because he he needs time to
calculate Bishop takes H3
um and so he'll probably spend some time
doing that in the meantime uh we've got
a lot of results uh martinovich bit pull
outs oh let's check back into this
Morrison game against your dekesco
which uh had turned in White's favor
after it was definitely better for for
black at some point
now we have an end game with time
Control Made what do you make of this
wrestling looks like white is still in
charge
uh yeah because uh I mean uh black
should take I guess on H5 no
right but then check on G6 and Entei and
Rook uh
why not on H7 in fact because that F6
you cannot play yeah because if you take
if you take on G4 then Knight E3
is uh almost made black is turning me
well okay it's again Knight G3 is still
a move but uh you can draw with that F6
also and Roxy side yeah of course
but if we look for more then uh another
moves Knight G3 is a pawn but I don't
like it somehow so uh what about Rook F6
now it's just a repetition ah Rook Rook
Rook have six at which point uh after uh
in that Rook g493 F6 yeah it could be a
an interesting option but roxy7 I don't
know Roxy oh and then are there any
crazy
like if the Rook was gone from F6 you'd
have Knight F6 but somehow uh yeah well
um but it's impossible too yeah
but of course it looks like very
promising for white if you start from uh
move one after the move after after Rook
takes H5 but I I I anyway I I just don't
see another move for black I mean black
has because if you take I don't know
what else uh White can do you mean
Knight takes D4 yeah but that doesn't
work right just Knight G5 they're losing
yeah and then Rook G6 is an Intermezzo
yeah exactly so and yeah should be just
just lost so critical is to take on H5
and then
of course does white doesn't have to to
do everything all these uh the check is
a possibility but maybe there is another
more I don't know what about uh so if I
play rookie 5 to somehow been still
Knight D4 is is is possible so counter
attacking that roof exactly yeah uh
otherwise and then okay check looks like
very logical no and yeah it does and
then collect and then Knight E3 and then
I would go Knight G3 maybe uh-huh
so then you've got good winning chances
here yeah still not clear but okay but
of course uh I guess take and Rook D7 so
not so easy to win that
yeah because Black's got a lot of
activity like one strike takes D4
happens there's yeah the king is open
yeah the king is so it's closer to draw
of course
yeah much closer to Jordan winning so I
don't see I don't see a problem for
black for the moment
but yeah
okay
very interesting interesting position
here we'll we'll see how this unfolds
um we I I did want to check into the
game of uh pragnananda who is another
crowd favorite he's a very and we'll
look at the nihal siren game also which
which might end up being a very long
game because that is a close Center
but uh once I hunt down the frog game
it looks like that one might be
close to finishing let me just
find that one Let me refresh this one
while I'm looking for it yeah 94
has been played oh
yeah yeah this is the position where
where black is simply thinking
uh there's a fragment on the game
this just looks probably winning for
almost winning for black
um
not so clear I mean it should be somehow
winning but it's also true that uh
Rook endings if the if for example if
white if Black Goes uh E3 I think then
just Knight C6 and I don't see a way
immediately but it should be somehow
winning that's true
so it's yeah white complain so you're
saying ic6 here
ah it's white to move it's right to move
yeah yeah
but then maybe uh Bishop first first
check of First bishop C5 yeah check
right
F1 Bishop C5 and somehow the knight uh
well the bishop is much stronger of
course so it looks close very close to
winning you know
yeah it does E3 and for example if if uh
Knight E5
which look then Bishop D4 I guess
and then it looks very close to winning
yeah
G8 is just E3 so I don't
yeah there's a nice line like if Knight
C4 you could play okay Rick F2 probably
wins but you have E2 and then Bishop F2
also
oh yeah
yeah they're in this kind of situations
always there are
one or two ways but it looks very close
to winning
yeah frog looks like he's on the way bro
swimming is a very talented player we we
do have our production team is telling
us that we do have an upset
and that is in the women's section uh
Anna oshenina who is of course ex uh
women's world champion
she has lost uh her game and I'm gonna
find that in just a second she has lost
her game
to IMO atas from Egypt I believe yes
in 41 moves wow look at that final
position
King on H5 is going to be checkmated
an incredible attack
mm-hmm
so what is the rating so oh she's 2 000
rating only
yeah
or and she sacked a rook here and
delivered Checkmate here
brilliant no
because uh A4 A4
and F5 was very nice
yeah this position F4 realizing that she
needs to close down the kingdom probably
black had some defense maybe black can
play out five herself
um I guess not evolve artist agrees
could be could be yeah could be why not
I mean
but then maybe still G4 I don't know but
yeah there's never Queen G6 because of
the circle f8
oh Queen G8 also so yeah
but but it like looked like uh
a better try no F5
yeah probably I think Anna just sort of
panicked with bd7 yeah maybe she just
missed yeah there's Queen Gina now
that's my last five it could be it could
be that she simply uh believed that she
was attacking on D2 and she missed the
move queen queen H7
uh right that's a key move because that
road can be it also defends the pawn on
D2
incredibly so in any case I mean
incredible attacking effort by Motas
thank you sir still still oh yeah yeah
she has one one uh a game with the white
pieces so fairly fairly good chances to
to recover you know it's not completely
over for sure
oh yeah absolutely not over and
um she will be trying to trying to win
her game tomorrow
um and we will be taking a short break
after which we will resume our coverage
of the 2021 fide World Cup presented by
chess.com
uh we'll be back in a few
um don't go anywhere world's cop resumes
after this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the feed a World Cup
Tournament Arc 2 begins on July 16th in
this second edition YouTubers from the
anime Community will face stars from the
world of fighting games Sea Dog VA
returns to the seeking Redemption that's
the first tournament Arc Champion higuk
rest of the field includes Daniel
rustage it's a John crazy Ollie and more
tune into chess.com to catch the action
and get more info at go.chess.com T A2
that will be coming your way on July
16th four days from now but right now
uh we are right in the midst of the
first game of the first matchup of the
uh fide Worlds Cup I'm honored to be
joined today by former world champion of
the legend Grand Master of Excellence
apollov it's been a very interesting
round so far vessel and not too many
surprises
but we might we might see a couple of
upsets here as a lot of the games are
definitely past the halfway point
yeah well okay uh I would say uh again
uh
this game now we have operant uh he
couldn't be able to to win it looks like
it's going to end a draw but it's not
such a big thing I would say uh it's a
young guy underrated I mean a guy who
plays not not so often I guess and um
this kind of platform India and Sri
Lanka there's so many I think uh it's
not a complete surprise that uh uh a
young boy can help to draw to a strong
gun Master actually I did play your
party not last week in France so we and
in a draw but again uh uh General as I
said General level I believe is very
very high it's getting better because uh
computers change everything and in the
past they were we were especially in
openings it was very very easy to to get
a huge Advantage sometimes and to win
quickly and now it looks like everybody
has uh these engines and they prepare so
the first 20 15 moves it's forget it I
mean most almost everybody knows the
main Theory and that's I believe is the
reason that uh uh that that also that
that's the reason I I always favor the
quicker time controls because in the
past
you know people they were starting to
think and to create a move them but now
it's clearly not the case I mean now you
can easily go to move 15 or even
sometimes 20. and that's the reason we
don't need so much time so the the real
moves we we think to we create uh less
than uh in a 40
move game uh are less than before
uh so
but again the the the the general level
is very high now and it becomes more and
more difficult to win a game and almost
impossible to win a queen game right
and everybody knows how to put their
pieces like it used to be that I mean of
course I wasn't entirely playing at that
time but there were some players who
just had very clear weaknesses you know
in 22 2300 range and now most Masters
say they're very competent in most parts
of the game they have no like huge holes
in their game
and and everybody's also expecting
surprises I think you used to be able to
play a sideline like E4 G6 and that's it
people would be out of their Theory but
now people study all of the sidelines as
well exactly so everything is known like
there's no such thing as like unexplored
we only play something unexplored it's
not possible
and it and it becomes very risky
sometimes because uh even a line that's
a bit worse uh uh I mean it can easily
become very dangerous to play uh this
side dubious openings for sure but even
uh even if you get the worst position
they players that are supposed not to
you know to to know how to play uh they
they've learned so and World Cup I think
even even when I was when I played 2004
I remember first round I met some Libyan
player and it's okay I won but it was
not that easy I mean even with white I
mean I one but it was not 20 moves it
was just uh pressing and increasing the
advantage and finally one but it was not
very quickly at all
and it's getting
and uh I mean
everyone is getting stronger and
stronger
yeah it'll be crazy to see like the next
couple of years uh the reshuffling of of
ratings at the top and among regular GMS
who have to play and opens and and face
these players all the time so
um this game that we're that is in front
of us apart and has provided that I mean
he manages to manages to get a bishop
out of this which is insane because it
was rook and Bishop and two versus rook
and Bishop and two it's still a draw
though if black knows what to do
so of course it is but of course I I
wouldn't be I wouldn't like to to defend
uh uh rook and Bishop against Rook with
little time I mean it's better to be
precise and not to lose the F7 pawn and
to have a fortress like that so it
shouldn't be difficult you know to to
make a draw but of course it's not
completely over
and it could be that this game lasts for
50 more moves oh yeah because why could
win one pawn and then another pawn and
all of that could take 30 moves each
so we'll keep an eye on it
looks like uh White will win the H3 pawn
and then it will you know it will
continue for long and especially in this
mini matches even when you're slightly
better you and extra time uh it's it's
completely different you have to try
even if you have little chances
especially situations with little risk
you have to keep on playing I mean one
has to push yeah exactly the one has to
push and try Until the End these
situations
yeah yeah that's very logical
well risk freeze risk-free situations
are the best of course and this is the
the typical situation when Oparin I
think he will try
mad and it's that is uh
yeah that makes a lot of sense and
that's a really really good Insight
um so let's let's have a look again at
the at the mystery game which continues
to evolve jababa okay so we were we were
looking at this point
Knight takes G3 Bishop H3 jababa played
takes takes Rook G1
and now by door trading everything on G3
and covers with Bishop H5 I guess
uh yeah Bishop G4 sorry
I believe Bishop G4 is better because
that doesn't allow the queen to enter uh
into the well okay now check in Queen H6
so it's not complete no it's not true
but it is a question for example Queen
F4 Queen F5
check
and then what if I go to G8 so for the
moment there are no checks
and black but it's it's not clear that's
more than
um
well black starts his checks and also
sometimes yeah but now I collect the
pawn on A3 with check I play Queen F1
Queen H3 Queen E3 with Ah that's a great
that's a great point so I cannot abandon
that pawn no it means that uh
it means that King G2 is stronger so
white can try to activate his King if
Black start checking but then C 3 and C2
I don't know it's not
it's uh it's not like
um
White
uh the black uh promoted yet but he's
close should be winning somehow I that's
the the impression should be yeah yeah
see too many threats against white skin
not enough counter play for white and
yeah yeah this does look it's not a
hundred percent clear I mean I mean the
queen goes to C6 sub checks
but again it should be winning
yeah but I mean yeah this is going to be
holding on Hope and what about the move
like Queen Queen F5 now
also a good option now that's
the queen F5 and then and then still
here then I go
Bishop G4 but 15 H2 yeah but then Queen
H4 oh
yeah so that's so which movie were you
saying I was saying I was I was trying
to check with with the bishop still on
H3 I was I was trying to check
but it should be somehow winning uh here
maybe here yeah King G7 and then Queen
Knight H4 check and then you cover and
then start check from C7 so I don't know
yeah you try to get black spaces and
this is not uh so clear Maybe
that makes sense and so very important
position for jabala I mean Bishop G4
Bishop F5 between F5
all possible candidate moves I I found
wrestling I don't know if you agree with
this these time controls with 30 minutes
added are very tricky because you you
get under the impression that you have a
ton of time but then it's very easy to
spend like 30 minutes all of your time
on move 41 because you you were in time
pressure so it feels like a lot of time
but it evaporates almost instantly
no I mean honestly I do like the time
control it's quite Dynamic uh it's it's
you one can still create a very very
good quality game but it's also not as
as long as uh the classical seven hour
games it's a bit short so I I like it
but of course it's especially when you
combine it to a knockout event the
pressure is very high I mean there's a
lot of tension and I I believe it favors
really a lot all these well guys that
there now they they were invited to all
this Grand Prix Magnus tournaments and
also the the tournament Casper uh
organized uh because they they're both
strong enough in slow chess In classical
chess but also in Rapid and Blitz so I
mean it's
uh is in in normal in the normal mini
match the two games if they don't beat
you then still their favorites in
Blitzen in the time break so they're
already also young experienced uh fit uh
I you know personally I I believe that
uh I miss a lot Wesley saw I think he
would be a very big container uh
Contender to win because he's extremely
strong in Rapid and all these Blitz and
Rapid time controls but of course also
he's one of the strongest players now in
classical uh and
I don't know the reason he declined but
uh I think he would be one of the the
perfect uh you know the perfect player
to win such an event
wow that's again some very very good
insights and he got a very diligent
hard-working production team creating a
really interesting graphic here which
displays
um all of the chess.com streamers and
commentators
uh who are participating in the world
cup and you see in the women's and the
open sections a lot of I mean very
mouth-watering names there
um I mean of course Nemo is playing in
the women's section Dina ballenkaya
Carissa and we have a lot of GM's
version of the Arvin some of them are
seated directly into the second round so
that's why they weren't playing the
first for Android Tang of course whose
game we will have a look at in just a
moment so lots of chess.com presents
here
okay so let's check back into that
Andrew Chang Pawn end game because I
think that
while I was checking it off the
broadcast
um things upon it
um sundarov came up with I think a
really cool
idea for counter play in an end game we
thought was quite convincingly winning
for white so let me click back into that
game
once I find it
yeah but um I think he found a way to
create
to create a past Pawn there it is
okay this is the game
but still I think after age five
and then I think the idea is A4
yeah but then uh again A4 take C4 and
then I guess take and H4 I don't know or
first G4 I think it's just uh take and
G4
take H4 and you're just not not in time
d5h oh yeah because the king stops the
pawn wait a second I I don't am I crazy
D5 H2
3d6
oops
this might not be so clear right because
King F7 has G5 yeah it's very
interesting in fact and King Alfred I go
F6 and I create this little binds okay
but then maybe I go like this
and then again King D6 yeah that's true
king D5 King D5 here I know
no no King not King B5 yeah maybe King
E8 wins
wait but now we go I go G5 H2 F7
okay thanks G6
ah
oops
and create incredible yeah I've never
seen this before
yeah yeah yeah yeah so after the idea is
G6 King ag7 and black is overwhelmed
yeah so let's go back then from uh
but anyway I guess the move
um
I guess the move
so if I
if I start with King F6
and then you're going on move one also
like that at the beginning of the common
the whole sequence what about
something like this here
take C4 take
here and now maybe now I can also play
uh like this I don't know or or for take
yeah if you go H5 so I'll probably go D5
no I won't
I guess you you have to but to yeah
because now I just take it and or
if you take I'll go King C5 but then
it's on the check yeah who
but of course it's what I promote first
yeah that's true yeah
it will be so it's not completely over
well it should be winning for black
that's my impression but uh yeah of
course
but this is hard to calculate I think
now we see why what if I go what if I go
um
I don't know each phone maybe H4 now
in this position oh G for now
one two three
yeah G4 I'll take it
maybe if I can even
take take I don't know I take of course
I take because
and now D6 G3 yeah yeah that's winning I
don't I don't make it in time with my
king because the moment you play D7
Michael's King E7 so I guess I guess I
have to drop my king back to D3 yeah but
then I just take the pawn so it's oh
wait a second what if I go King D5
well it doesn't change much I think
because he takes
C6 and then but even if we promote and
then maybe I just check and collect
uh and collect but then with a pawn of
course there's always chances I mean if
I push G4 so so I'll take it
yeah okay thanks
yeah that's that's not so clear I guess
Queen C1 I think is what you wanted to
play could be should be a draw yes as
long as white doesn't play I can't take
anymore exactly no this should be a draw
of course I mean
um maybe five can take day five and I
think probably Perpetual yeah I mean
there's no no well
it should be already uh dead draw now
almost
yeah those are some insane complications
again King D5 uh King D5
so if I
you mean
G for take Taking e for G3 I don't know
who it's is it uh
I think it's a draw it takes takes King
E4 if you're on time to you know to to
reach C1 of course yeah I'm in Thailand
by a Tempo though I only buy its info
we'll see that is enough
so Andrew is he okay so things have
happened here
um if I'm not mistake Let me refresh to
make sure I'm not
I'm not the one making these moves okay
yeah this has happened Andrew has played
H5 A4 take this D4 so this is happening
we might see this insane
insane variation on the board with D5
and G5
no definitely uh black has to take
otherwise C5
well I don't know about move like let me
see uh what if
what if I go uh H4 now then
it makes no sense no it makes no sense
simply just take and kink moves no it
makes no sense
here it can or even C5 it's C5 maybe
even winning for a while yeah
no no black has to take black has to
take and then index now the question is
H4 G4 or King F6 right oh that is a well
King F6 I think I think okay yeah yeah
this is working 85 is the move that's
right
yeah
that is hard to say I mean I think with
black it's no it's very easy to see D5
but like King D5 is insane
wow yeah so if so again uh H4 or G4
or each four like this or maybe H2O so
here D5 okay now if I go King somewhere
then you play D6 or no no where do I go
with the King because then I I'm running
to now I'm running to G5 check if I go
yeah but the thing is if you go to f8 I
can already go King D4 yeah
no of course of course yeah
so I have to hurry uh like I mean maybe
I should have played G4 and to force you
to take
so on the previous move G4 let's take
here D5
and div I mean h4d5 so if we if we
bought
um
yeah so King
f8 now King f8 what was King f8 okay
King f8 okay d6h2h5 H2 yeah oh wait a
minute now you might be promoting but F6
no no no F6 exactly yeah I mean here H3
H3 D6 move and then we cut oh my
goodness this is the line yeah this is
what we looked at yeah
this is what this is the move that saves
the game for white without it black
promotes but F7 King F7 I'll just show
this again for the crowd G6 check and
one Pawn is replaced by another but this
other Pawn is further from the king so
Black's King is overextended
amazing
no but in in this case oh now uh White
promotes with checks so it makes no
white is playing for a win maybe well
almost that's a draw of course but but
uh
looks it looks drawish now if this is
all always see if we don't miss anything
then uh she looks strong do you think uh
cindariff sees this uh this F7 check
idea or is he just going for it because
he has to I I think he sees it by the
way what is his age because the picture
I look at yeah looking for
I mean it looks like my daughter almost
oh look him up he is 15. ah okay but he
still looks maybe he's younger than 15.
it's early picture well where's he from
sorry you you're crazy
Who's ah sorry okay good
yeah
and
wow yeah he's very very promising he's
played in
Junior speed chess championships
okay so let me refresh again I feel like
yeah so this is the position hgh4d5 this
is all happening
I think the reasons I think the reason
he will he would find this Musa because
they're only moves I mean they're like a
human make mistakes when they have a
choice but in this case it's uh either
you lose or or you you I mean the the
ways we calculate uh we take decisions
uh sometimes because we eliminate things
that obviously lose and here uh when you
see easily that all the black promotes
his Queen
so the only the only way to stop it is
to you know to
um
to to prevent it then of course you find
this I just don't don't think uh uh
right uh only only moves even if they
are very difficult they are in fact
easier to find than situations where you
have choice
yeah even if the move is easier I
believe in chess the the the most
difficult
um thing is when you have to choose
between two similar situations a
situation when you have two bad choices
or two good choices but when you only
have one good choice or one bad uh one
uh choice that is losing and you just
don't have to you eliminate it so it's
much easier to to take it to this to the
site
that's a great that's a great Point
um and here we go King f8
is played um F6 king8 is going to happen
and yeah I mean white can play F7 check
first it doesn't actually matter you can
play F7 or you can play G5
and black will not take a draw me to
like Andrew will play Queen C1 in the
end and take the pawn but zandara it
looks like we'll escape this game with
an incredible study-like draw
and uh that is that yeah that's a that's
got to be that's got to feel good for
him
so so many young and promising players
that I honestly I just don't know all
the names
yeah I don't either it's it's impossible
to keep up it's like the new Grandmaster
literally pops up I think every every
two months so
and now we have Mishra
um incredible incredible so okay
speaking of Mr let's let's have a look
at
how that game is proceeding we
definitely ownership one by the way
probably
so a lot of results kind of as expected
Oparin has rook and Bishop against rook
and by the way Oparin is making some
progress he's pushed black to the edge
but this is that idea of trick F7 yeah
it is also true that for the moment
black is holding the correct defense I
mean he has the seventh rank so uh I
mean only only what he has to do is to
play King E7 and back so uh even with
the even I mean uh even let's say if the
Rook is now on uh let's say Rook Gia
check I think
and then King E7 only move rookie uh
here I think now the the correct move is
uh yes exactly D7 so every time you
check I still black has to uh Bishop E6
go back yeah Yep this looks winning
right but it's not but why there's no
way to where there's nothing just
checking and white truck has to go back
one of the one of the uh positions that
the the good defense but of course it's
also there were some
tricks to to break but in fact it's it's
strange it never happened to me uh with
wow I decides no yeah you're incredible
neither side I
I mean
uh I wouldn't but again I I wouldn't
like to to to to defend this kind of
situation positions with with uh with
little time
right no it's I I had it twice actually
I had it once on the defending side
against your malinsky in in time
pressure and once again where I had the
bishop and you he came close to
blundering a few times but he was
playing only on time delay like he had
almost no time and he managed to make a
draw so but even you know there's all
the positions when even if you are uh to
the eighth rank if a situation if the
King goes to D6 imagine and then two to
d8 if white gets to D6 through the eight
then it's uh lost but if you get get to
basic and B8 it's a draw with the with
the second with with the Rook on the C1
even if you have a situation a position
with King B6 Bishop B5 against King B8
and white Rook on G7 even that's a draw
yeah and sometimes even the winds are
hard to win like finding that there's
some wins which have like seven
different winning moves in a rook there
they're there uh so it's sometimes the
win is even harder with with with 30
seconds to move uh it's easy to go wrong
for both sides yeah yeah I think uh I
think it was Carolina he when we played
in I think it was in 2000
uh let me see one of the candidates he
had a fairly good chance against swedler
and then he got to this
rook and Bishop and then at some point
he was winning and he just couldn't find
it or he couldn't remember
so and that was the reason he couldn't
qualify for that match uh he qualified
for the next match against Magnus I
think but he had a fairly good chance to
qualify or it was caruano or Levon I
don't remember
I think it was scar one I vaguely
remember the game you're talking about
yes so
yeah
so this might be the last game remaining
we don't know we'll we'll see
um but this will go for long yeah it'll
go Forever Until 50 moves yeah
okay
he is not not doing a bad job defending
this so bad or played Richard G4
s we're guessing many moves yeah yeah
yeah we I think we have this position
our analysis and now we thought about C3
C3 Queen C6 I guess and then if you
check then I have uh King F2 so I'm
defending the pawn yeah oh yeah yeah so
for the moment black is uh no so C2
looks logical and now the question is
all these checks white that white has uh
is black able to prevent uh all these
checks and to escape with the King I'm
not so sure you know that uh even most
like uh let's say King G King G3
disabled attention sometimes in these
situations because uh not so for for the
moment uh it's not so easy to promote
and if if you play a move like king
queen I mean queen
um
three four uh maybe some checks start I
don't know now I'm starting with checks
from E8 so yeah this looks like a drive
I mean yeah with Perpetual Queen D5 is
also what if could you go H4 here no no
that's yeah but just take it yeah I mean
the Knight protects perfectly you know
this right
so
then
yeah it's not easy to find a motor I
mean it's a mutual mistakes are very
possible
King I mean uh let me see King
King G3 but but that's not that's
probably not the only move I don't know
I don't know queen queen E5 check for
example is another optional or start
checking immediately I could also
what if I just start checking yeah
yeah I mean these positions are so hard
to calculate
um I mean even seeing the engine evalu
it just doesn't tell you very much about
the Practical evaluation and by the way
we do have an upset
who is a Russian
Grandmaster he lost to Star scan to
ravihari a very dangerous I am from from
England
um I think I mean we're looking at this
game but it was a very nice positional
effort by hariya who take it all the way
to the end and
yeah he won what seems like a very very
nice
very very nice positional game
just took all his pawns and then traded
Knights and won The Rook end game very
convincing yeah good good technique yeah
good technique Well Done by Aria yeah we
won't analyze this carefully because
we've got
plenty of games still ongoing
okay so we also have this game where
okay black was completely winning but
now I'm not so sure it's that clear
anymore it was it's the game between
Kevin go Grandmaster from Singapore and
Enriquez Viagra from
um
from Chile
from Chile and I still think black is
winning but it's gotten a little bit
complicated Andrew Tang by the way has
drawn his game against or rather the
other way around cindarov has drawn
again of course and also true it's also
that uh time the time trauma is coming
but it still looks winning no I mean if
I just take my I could just I can black
and just collect the the bishop no then
I tell me B5 yeah but I mean okay queen
queen can just go to F6 Queen goes to F6
uh you don't and you have to collect and
then uh yeah
yeah no it's for sure it's winning I
mean you don't I mean white doesn't even
have uh a way to Pro to to advance his
Pawn no it's completely winning still
yeah I just got
I got I got too excited it's just a
night and the beep on is easily
constrained it's simply a little bit
less winning than it was probably yeah
but it's still still enough enough
winning
doesn't look very big problem
so we have yeah we have a lot of has one
by the way
but I have one against uh Keystone very
also very convincing game look at that
final position Total Domination yeah
yeah
it looked much better right from the
beginning uh and then but I thought he
was black you know are you sure he's
white
oh yeah yeah I guess I can see it
because it made more sense originally we
thought it was black the colors were all
messed up but I was surprised by Ray I
was thinking in this pretty common
position
uh with wagon right I'm sure you said it
before so I guess it was like it was
kizona was thinking who was not as
familiar with this line
and yeah explains that explains it I
think because beref is also playing with
Slough with the black so I I wasn't
really surprised uh to to play to have
this position
yeah well we also explained like onus
shook played we thought it understood
Alexander ownership played E4 which she
never does but okay it's the world you
know maybe you prepare it
as you said but it turns out that he was
actually he was actually black so some
of the colors were originally messed up
we apologize for that
in any case we've got some interesting
games we haven't checked out today
Euro Vasquez who is a um very very
strong International Master 2527 from
Power 20.
it's playing Nikita meshkov's
Grandmaster from Latvia and looks like
black is completely winning here
should be yeah well it's never
completely clear never completely yeah
but
um
yeah two pounds up I mean even if uh
White is able to eliminate the D2 pawn
and exchange it for the the one of cc6
which is not completely impossible that
would be clear to pause up for black and
yeah looks winning of course
um so so we have a
Chilean Grandmaster I uh
with fairly good chances to advance to
the second round
I think his children
Vasquez is from Paraguay oh sorry and
he's actually still an I am which is
amazing to me because he's he's beaten
so many strong GMS I I there's a couple
of these IMS who are like 25 70 25 80
it's insane to me that they're not
Sheamus yet but I guess the pandemic
also made it difficult to get norms
yeah that explains a partially stopped
stopped them for a couple of years
almost
yeah but I don't know I don't know if uh
it's possible to to get together uh
title uh for win for advancing in the
World Cup I mean because in a tournament
it's clear but for World Cup uh I don't
know what the rules I mean what I when I
became a grand master it was 1990 at the
end of 91. I guess maybe half of the
players on the World Cup they were not
even born
so I don't remember but what I I needed
only two Norms because the first class
tournament I I played was 15 rounds and
they don't do that anymore I mean I
think so you've got like a double Norm
exactly so I I only need it two two
norms
and then but both from close tournaments
right who do you remember the game sorry
go ahead
no I mean uh when I
when I got this second the uh I was 16
almost 17 and it was considered a good
age back then right right great age yeah
at the beginning oh okay it was not
Fisher when he was 15 I think but uh
still it was considered okay
from the youngest Grandmasters yeah I
basically became a GM from the
retirement home at age 17 it's like
time to think about you know
time to think about quitting a job and
now it's younger and younger yeah it's
crazy but it's I mean it used to be much
much more difficult somehow I think I
don't know
yeah it sounds like it's a combination
of things
uh
I'm looking at jobava because
he apparently he found some move we
didn't consider and he placed well I
don't know if this queen is well placed
on
a game he played Bishop E2
and sometimes I don't know if that's
really a threat to you know to
um
to to play Queen F1 you know because I
don't see him mate I mean if the king if
the white king advances but uh maybe
they're in fact yeah maybe there is this
trick
but
I don't see well
if if Queen moves to let's say
um
if the
Queen moves to B6 or to C6 to start
giving checks
oh so you're saying Queen V6 in this
position yeah but I mean if you go
somewhere there then
already Queen f1.21 yeah yeah but Queen
G1 is not such a big problem I mean I go
King F4 uh King H4 I would go so it's
not the end but we have to
yeah but our King G5 take a and and go
up ah it's not even well maybe King F6
and then wow so it's not six yeah but
still uh may it should be winning
somehow for black right
yeah but I mean like you said should be
um is I mean maybe Queen H6 and queen G7
and then Bishop D3 no I I guess first uh
first
yeah also exactly also there's because
the king hides on H7 yeah that is true
even you can play immediately to H7
ah yeah no it's uh this is clearly but
so I got over optimistic so what if I go
King G3 immediately just to see what you
you play
how do you yeah you're proposing that in
a different position I really like this
one because yeah it's prophylaxis at the
end of the day again but then uh I don't
know what
if okay if black advances with uh
C3 then we go back to uh Queen C6
and now there's no Queen F1 yeah
so black needs to set up some sort of a
black needs a counter prophylactic move
yeah so H4 would be nice if white takes
with with uh with the King because then
Queen H7 but then after king after Queen
takes still no no not clear no what do
you think of Bishop F1 here
but what's the point
so I have Queen H3 in case you go Queen
C6 ah okay but then King advances to F4
yeah and then and then okay I didn't see
anything specific I just thought maybe
Queen
yeah but yeah there's probably nothing
but maybe I I can even go back to F3 so
I don't see okay it was played
it was played
yeah I like I like when they go back to
30 seconds with increment with no
additional time they yeah this is fun
this is this is when it gets interesting
uh
it makes sense
so what uh
no okay I mean uh white black and gold
C3 and if you go with the queen to C6
then H4 has to be considered because
then I play Queen F2 and I take
uh Jack with check so then we would get
same situation without the pawn on H5
which shouldn't matter
uh so this is the question now
if I push I I don't see another that's
the only useful move to move your queen
I guess no and then H4 take Queen f
uh Queen F2 and okay of course I can go
up but I can also go to to G2
queen queen
uh King H3
if you take I get King G2 so check
checks are over but but it's true that
uh
it's sex checks over but it should be
somehow winning I don't know not so easy
I mean you're let's say I guess some
move like Bishop H5 then
where is this after
I think uh what my the line I'm looking
at Queen C6 now
of course it has to be found but I think
uh Queen C6 H4
take
check on these two and then okay we have
this should be
losing here take King G2 yeah and then I
thought Bishop H5
oh to cover all the square all the key
squares well I I'm not sure I'm covering
because because Queen who no no no no no
Queen E6 Queen E7 should draw because
now you don't have really uh yeah you're
going to lose if you go to a square then
I can discover a check this is a draw
now so yeah because my queen is not
protected and if I check before then of
course the pawn on C3 is hanging so yeah
it's not so easy so I don't know yeah
how would you how would you go after
King G2 uh because
I mean
no this is a draw
yeah just one gets the sense that like
with six minutes it's very difficult to
find anything but we are going to take a
very quick break and then when we come
back we're gonna stick on on this game
we're going to watch the time scramble
whether bador can find any chances we
will be right back do not go anywhere
the most fun part of the round the time
scramble is coming right up we'll be
right back
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the 2021 v-day World Cup
the chess kid junior speed Chess
Championship the jscc is happening now
through August 8th join some of the top
Junior players in the world as they
compete for a 25 000 prize fund that
tournament
is heating up as you can see in the
bracket some mouth-watering names I've
been commentating some of those matches
you definitely do not want to miss it if
you haven't been following it closely so
far a lot of cool matches coming your
way all the way through August 8th but a
lot more cool matches coming your way
now
sorry is there the ages or the points
you saw here next to the names
um that should be let me see that should
be the points oh yeah because I wouldn't
be surprised okay there's one guy even
you know I was believed you because I
thought at first yeah it's plausible
like if they all had over 10 points it
could be their ages
that's funny
yeah two-year-old I mean give it 30
years wrestling we'll see somebody at
two and a half like I am first I am Norm
at three years old
okay and they said Bob benickler and
Chess at 12 so that would be Unthinkable
now
exactly yeah okay so uh let's see
so black is to move now uh yeah the
Knight is quite strong I would say on E5
so good good wrong chances yeah I mean
fact in fact the also you know the pawn
on D5 is hanging so with check uh
oops Black's done good well
so it means queen queen G5 with black
ghost Queen G5 uh only way not to get
mated is to go King F3 from what I see
now right
yeah because King F2 of course is made
Queen G2 Queen E2
and then uh we can of course collect the
pawns with check it means that I can
collect uh with check
here
but then yeah here and we were talking
about this position
well yeah and now should be winning or
not
where does the king go yeah you were
proposing I think King F6 earlier yeah
but then Queen F4 check
four I think and then Ah that's bad just
winning just winning
yeah so I guess then King King takes H5
maybe maybe you collect that pawn
yeah King exactly but that does that
change much and then
going to oops
it should be it's so hard to figure out
which check to give here of course I can
check twice
it makes I mean check and check on D3
makes sense no and then yeah D3 and then
you take because otherwise uh Queen H6
simply so don't I mean if you go back to
H5 what happens now uh
well by the way badur has not done that
he's got H4
yes
so soon we'll see soon we'll see so he
has to go to H I think he has to go to
H5
yeah it doesn't matter if the pawn is
there or not it's not actually well the
only Square it was covering is G4 but
White's not going to G4 what if I go to
F uh to F6 you mean then
check on F4 and then what why not just
one somehow moving but you're I think
Still Still Queen H6 may be winning
because Knight she's like nothing has
changed and you mean and then you mean
you just uh check and check and kink uh
H7 yeah
that's true that is true looks so looks
completely winning yeah Mishra with a
huge decision only four minutes to make
it there there's some difference because
because the pawn on H uh five it was not
there there was some difference but
still should be winning of course true
but yeah I think that's C4 like if you
get any of these like uh Knight versus
Bishop end games they're often lost you
know during the lockdown I've been
thinking about that play with
with the mask
with the mask if you're in a lost
position I think your the natural desire
is to abandon now to to resign I mean if
you have to play with the face mask
because uh simply in a normal situation
you would try to save the game and it
doesn't matter if it lasts 10 hours but
if you think you're going to lose if
it's close to very bad a whole place
it's uh you know the natural desires to
to get rid of the Mask as quickly as
possible so the the one the one with an
advantage has the extra psychological
advantage why do you think why is that
just because it's uncomfortable exactly
I mean because if you think you have
very slow little chance of uh you know
saving a game then you rather get rid of
the mask and then you simply resign
but without mask of course you can try
because it's not I mean it's not so
uncomfortable I mean you don't have it
without mask I mean maybe they should
make a rule where if you take your mask
off that's that that is how you resign
like because now of course people don't
shake hands so maybe just taking your
mask all right
what I mean is that uh okay
very few very few of the players they
actually wear masks here but still you
know there are several uh several
players I saw the the the the images
and uh it's the worst uh the worst uh
you can get to a very bad passive
position maybe close to losing and uh
and then has to to defend it with mask
well at least then your opponent can't
see how disappointed you are in your
play I I experienced this as I played
one tournament just recently and I found
that when I make a mistake it's I don't
I don't have to hide my my rage I can
just I can be incredibly upset and it's
harder to tell what's someone's feeling
yeah
so but yeah so jobik is very close to
win to winning somehow let me see the
time
yeah with extra one minute but okay It's
tricky because it you have 30 seconds so
sometimes it's about the position more
than about the time 30 seconds is
sometimes more than enough I mean
um
yeah so let's see I mean he's about to
be he's a minute
you can see him on camera here beautiful
shot by our uh production scene that's
awesome we see the clock you see the
board 45 seconds
and
okay I mean 30 second increment you
should take your time down to 10 seconds
if there is something to think about
there's no point in like you know
panicking
well it's easy that's easy for me to say
King F6
I think so you mean check check on G7
yeah and then King
H7 and that's it and I think it's over
yeah because okay Queenie six we only
try to go to click
knock but also Queen E6 I I can just
promote no because you don't even have
checks
I mean oh yeah I mean
I was gonna play with H3 but well I
don't think it's still made so right I
was thinking about some stalemate ideas
but there is just no no I was just about
to blend of the queen but but uh I just
yeah so this is already lost I mean
check check and then King moves
yeah it's I mean of course uh the as I
said the only difference now is that if
you go Bishop D3 then I have check from
H3
right so you don't want to do that so uh
it makes no sense but if uh so okay yeah
it's done it it's done all of it
instantly actually yeah it
okay it's not so difficult and now of
course uh it's what about Queen D6
then Queen H6 I think is obligator of
course of course of course yeah ah he's
in fact he's already threatening to to
collect the night even there's no way to
stop it exactly yeah it's over chibaba
is going to win and then yeah
so this match he as I said 90 90 chances
to to go to the second round
yeah you made a great point about uh
it's like having the psychological
advantage in the beginning
exactly yeah playing with black yeah I
mean this world cup uh I don't I mean I
never understood really because it is a
it is World Cup so for it is important
for everyone to say I am a World Cup
winner but at the same time it's only
one level of this world's Championship
cycle right I don't really believe that
the guys that qualified for the next
level should be allowed like Magnus or
and actually he doesn't play so it's uh
uh it's a bit strange
because he can interfere in the
influence the tournament yeah that's
that's a great point
uh
okay so Mr staking on D5 that's probably
the best that's uh
practical chance but it's not a serious
chance
that's a free piece and goodbye
basically
yeah thing out for maybe he's hoping for
some crazy Perpetual but
I think it's also in the way of
everything
okay I mean he can only lose one point
point I mean uh he can always resign
so no hurry right exactly and you
mentioned this from the other side like
if you have any chances to win you play
if you have any chances to draw
why why resign prematurely I mean yeah
because she no you resign because you
you get rid of the Mask
yeah
you can't win you can't oblige your
opponents to to resign if you're better
but if you're worse of course you can
resign quicker
right
so uh but yeah but also I mean World Cup
also sometimes because for important uh
players that really have ambitious to uh
the Ambitions to to play for the world
championship title of course uh it means
that the semi-final is more important in
the final because if they don't care
about money I mean there's no difference
in both players from the final qualify
in a way it means the qualifa the
semi-finalism becomes more important
than than the final because finals okay
the title and some money but it's uh the
main goal is to qualify for the
candidates and then of course the
semi-final is the important
see yeah that's that's uh completely
agree and okay the game seems to be
essentially over so we can switch to
some of the other remaining games
we have a pawn end game really
interesting Pawn on game in a game
between two GM and sparientos and
berkich
is playing Black Croatian Grandmaster
this looks like it's winning for black
if black can trade these these pawns
then the blockchain is much closer to
White spawn obviously but yeah how does
black how does he do that I mean we need
we need to summon divertsky here
yeah the way it goes is like for example
imagine why it goes F5 King E4 King G6
King F3
and right you from behind you sort of
waiting and simulate you'll have to and
then the question is if white is quick
to to reach the A3 square but I don't
think it hap it can happen simply yeah
if if anybody knows sorry go ahead
no I think it just lost uh I don't think
here King G3 wins I think or not
yeah I was just I was making an empty
move to show the triangulation I thought
maybe here King E4 and then
oh no no I guess not
what if you go G6 ah and if King G3 then
King D2 but it's King G5 then your idea
King F3 and this is winning exactly yeah
exactly so this is pretty simple and G6
has been played
so yeah um berkitch is going to win
against fairly good chances to to
advance yeah with also his 100 points uh
higher yeah
and playing with white he should he
should be able to you know to to win
right and um the match not not tomorrow
but the match right and G6 played King
G3 so that's king d2g or I'm just gonna
draw arrows to show takes takes
C1 F5 B2 F6 oh B1 check so the king is
gonna be on G6 and black is going to
promote with check that's the only
reason it's winning otherwise y would
have played F7 but yeah yeah
wow look at these little details but of
course I can also go I can also play uh
King E2 and King G4 King F2
wait say that again King G4 oh
same yeah
I think you can keep dropping no no no
no no no no no yeah yeah yeah like
you're getting you're playing with fire
early there's no need for that of course
yeah
yeah so that's uh that's a win okay
there's more interesting end games
Crossing off yo Baba just exchanged the
Queens okay
resigns and what about operin are they
still playing uh
oparan is
it was still a draw let me just check
the appearance
um it's yeah they're still in that end
game okay it's still still moving around
whoa wait a minute
this is a
apparently the the Evo bar shows that
white is winning here but again this is
what we talked about you get these
positions oh black is one second if we
could pan out to that game that'll be
really cool if we could see the time
scramble in action
as badur gets up from the table they're
signing their score sheets
yeah it looks like he was able to to
somehow trick yes and now he advances
with the King to F6 and that it's
winning completely uh that would be a
job if the bishop was on
uh dark Squad if you play if you have a
gate if you have King kick to F7 and
Bishop to
E7 that would be a draw
I think but now it's winning as I said
yeah with with no time
yeah
no it's impossible you get like one
little decision you got to make in 30
seconds and okay let's see he's played
Rook somewhere Rook G4 I think but when
you have to move your Rook away from
your king like that it means it means
you've screwed up yeah now now he has to
place it to
uh to H4 in fact okay I can see the
logic behind that because that's the
only way to to stop the mate no after
kick F6 yeah yeah Rook H5 but that's of
course uh uh check I guess Mr G6 on H6
I think then and then it's some move uh
well the thing is if you move your rock
then I've got Rook F4
ah
no of course I can yeah you you can also
make some other move here you can move
your roof or something yeah I think
maybe the key is to block picking around
to f8 It's like work F1 Bishop H5 is a
possibility well cutting off the rook
and then play place The Rook too if yeah
it's winning but uh still I mean
and and of course it's not so easy to to
play these positions uh when you see it
from this angle
yeah exactly it's like weirdly Twisted
you're used to seeing with the blacking
like on the eighth rank rather than the
H file
it's a theoretical position with uh
so now okay of course Bishop G6 is a
draw after Rook F4
um Rook F4 yeah yeah so
um we have to move the Rook to the
bishop somewhere else
yeah G6 is desirable from the
perspective of depriving the king of
squares but it deprives the king of too
many squares so
so it just go to E2 I guess
yeah and then the Rook moves and then
maybe to G4
okay I'll go back yeah but then I can go
Rook F2 or Rook like this also yeah yeah
Rock F2 and you can take the bishop so
share and then and then next uh somehow
should be Bishop F5 or G2 or G8
something like that yeah so uh with the
Rook for sure it's winning
right yeah so
apparent also has plenty of time to to
calculate all this in over 20 minutes so
yeah not those riveting end game but
definitely we'll uh we'll keep an eye on
this uh we've got a couple more results
a lot to love uh won his game against an
I am
the vast majority of games are done we
got Creek Bar
ooh Creek or trying to outplay
Gonzales Zamora Mexican GM and this is
I don't know what to make is this what
are the chances here that white wins
no I I guess it's just winning but uh of
course uh still not so easy because uh
sometimes white black tries to you know
to sacrifice
um
I think Knight C5 back should be the
correct move and then
oh and then check for B3
if you yeah and then Advance with the
King
so it's it is winning of course because
now uh in fact it's easily winning I
guess because if you go King D6 with the
idea to take I can just Advance King D4
and then yeah
simply C5 and then over again and again
no it's easily winning I mean white has
a good coordination
so uh as as long as as white does not
make a big mistake it's it's easy to
between Ah that's mehtarian he it
actually he it took him like 40 hours to
reach uh Sochi or maybe more really he's
a hero because uh I think he had some
problems to uh to to get to the plane in
in Brazil and then
he went after many many hours he reached
Moscow and I I don't think he had
a lot of rest before the game
yeah he's a trooper you know when I
played Libya uh that's
last well not the last knockout but uh
actually we we had problems with the
VISA so I actually arrived for the first
round uh uh during the you know during
the round so wow they postponed uh my
game for one hour so immediately from
the from the plane I went to play that's
insane and you had a lot I assume a very
long flight long journey uh no it was I
don't we were flying from Amsterdam I
don't remember how long the flight was
but and of course I lost my luggage it
came out of course yeah but again the
problem was that I had to to play to to
go from uh immediately from the
uh from the plane
that's that's insane yeah and I mean
recore has a lot of fans in the audience
he's he's awesome he's a streamer
commentator
um very accomplished so
a lot of people cheering him on
okay so he's probably going to take this
one all the way to the end
I'm looking there's just not a lot of
games left just a couple
um some of them are about to end and
draws
uh let's have a look at the women's
section and see
uh see if there are any games ongoing
there any surprises
um well
we do have okay we have maltesevskaya
Russian very very strong Russian women's
gym
still in an end game
I'm looking at yeah mostly mostly
results have been pretty predictable a
couple of small writing upsets oh yeah
we got a 2 000 beating another 2400.
Carolina Varela La Madrid
from Venezuela beating Pauline gishard
from France wow
another very stunning rating difference
right there but again still one more
game to play right
yeah
okay
and other than that essentially okay
I'll Mira scription Co
Phil has this end game against
a draw I think should be wow
just uh because there's no way to make
progress no but even if I if black
reaches C8 and sucks his Pawn his Bishop
for the pole I think it's still a draw
no
nice yeah oh yeah
yeah
I mean if I reach if I reach with with
the black king to C8 I think it's a draw
I don't think uh it's possible oh that's
like the Geary Shanklin game do you
remember that one where yeah yes yeah
exactly yeah
bad memories for Sam
but yeah
he can simply
um
should be a draw of course can place his
uh King to E6 and then move the bishop
so every time every time that uh a pawn
is a oh maybe it doesn't look like uh
well that's also a good option probably
but what if Almira tries in Bishop G3
and under survey yeah but then then of
course then of course I attack your Pawn
on B6 oh yeah
so long day yeah Bishop D3 yeah
I hope I I think you should go officer
you just hope that no he doesn't attack
it I mean uh
well but of course of course uh I just
don't see what can white do because uh
I mean every time the bishop moves then
the pawn on B6 is attacked and again the
only way to defend opponent is from C7
so it can easily be a repetition or you
uh give up the pawn from basics in order
to advance to
to G5 or G6 but then still the king's
not active enough there yeah this is
true yeah just this is yeah that's a
draw Okay so
what else is going on in this section we
have Dina bellancaya
who also who was completely lost just
down three Pawns in an end game now
is on the cusp of holding a draw
oh this is a very interesting end game
now she's got two ways to defend she can
move her King around or she could try
like Knight B3 Knight A5
yeah what is the downside of just moving
around does White have any winning
progress I guess I guess the problem is
uh that Kink moves to uh I mean night
night moves to F5 and then at some point
maybe you can get a position when white
plays uh
checks
yeah exactly
so black has to go here yeah but then
but then again I kind of play uh
King C7 for example yeah I gotta go now
A5 and then Knight moves to D6
get the same situation but like now on
the sixth rank which is not good yeah
but now I'm looking at C3 I guess okay
yeah and now of course
um one plan is if I can reach to 286
with my king I don't know if it's that
that's possible let's say if I go King
B8 well you could but but uh what you
could do is instead of King C7 maybe
Googling B7 also yeah but then King B5
looking at five I don't know I have King
D5 but then I Got King King here yeah
should be winning of course yeah and
then checking King A6 and once the pawn
is on B7 then should uh should be
winning of course
yeah this is such a hard decision to
make for Dina
okay Knight C8
with little time of course
yeah one minute on the clock so
you can see the playing Hall uh on on
your screen just a couple of games
remaining
this one very nail-biting nerve-wracking
for for Dina who's trying to save a dead
lost position earlier okay we'll keep an
eye on this one as well
let's um let's check back into the open
section
and see if we have any Alaskan Crossing
call of one Merson and the Articles
ended up in the dryer to kesco holding a
very tough position we got one game here
about to end
champakira about to beat by Chad say I
think this is just dead lost
yeah of course of course yeah and I
guess we've got our Most Fascinating
game I'm just kidding well oh wait this
is just over
q1
oh wait the next C5 this is definitely
already winning for a barn usually
there's like a check should be thrown in
here chicken chicken exactly yeah yeah
so maybe we could zoom in oh
King King uh you know King h8 in the end
oh not yet
where's the wind
yeah
okay but 45 modify somehow
uh
wait isn't Bishop F oh no no no no no no
yeah I managed to okay Rook G6 was
played okay nh5 display but our G3
yeah because uh this is over exactly
made on HD a client's gonna notice and
he's played Rook Q3 and this is a
heartbreaker for
finds young opponent who's still going
to hold us head up high I mean so close
to making a draw and he should she
shouldn't have allowed that Rook versus
Bishop end game it was it was just dead
drawn and I think he went after some
sort of speculative line where he took
upon Gregory and in fact I don't think I
I I I don't think it's even possible to
to lose the F7 Pawn you know it's just
very difficult to lose it you know yeah
he I don't think he tried to keep it up
I mean look at this line H4 takes
I guess he got himself into some weird
um he's like Bishop B3 just Bishop B5
I mean but then why Bishop yeah then
but even that even that okay after Rook
B4 ah then the king came to the king
came to aha okay yeah and then he took
the pawn and it still should be a dead
draw of course it was it was if you go
back I think it was a I know maybe on
the wrong yeah but then I mean how did
he give up that f-bun so quickly
he didn't really try to keep it I think
he pushed it no he shouldn't push that
is a big mistake Yeah Yeah the more you
push it the weaker it becomes yeah he
could just go King B4 a little B4 and
then whoops yeah wait yeah so that is a
big Miss but apparent yep he wins the
first game
and that leaves us essentially with I
think
I'm just looking around here Creek or is
still playing as he trying to
finish off a very nice technical effort
and he might be the last
left game remaining yep I believe he is
and uh as he tries to connect or we will
go on a short break when we come back
um what seems to be the final stretch of
the of day one of the feeder World Cup
don't go anywhere as the round winds
down a couple of nail-biting end games
remaining we will be right back with a
final stretch
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the feeding World Cup
presented by chess.com before we delve
into the final games the quick
announcement for the blitzcoin
Invitational that will be coming your
way late October I don't know who that
is on the cover I never asked anyone to
put put that person there but it will
feature some of the top top us players
25 and under
um again that'll be coming your way
right before the world championship
it'll be a fascinating format we'll be
playing for a prize fund of one Bitcoin
so it's a very Innovative new tournament
lots of combative chess so mark your
calendars I'll be playing in that and uh
trying my very best and that will be
also presented to you by Charlotte chess
Center which has been instrumental in
helping to organize this tournament
but in any case back to the concluding
part of day one of the fide World Cup
we've got krikor
uh vegetarian fan favorite trying to
convert an advantage against Carlos Juan
Carlos Gonzalez Zamora from Mexico and
vessel and I think he's about to put the
finishing touches on the skin
oh well definitely if I'm white I would
just Advance my king to D6 it looks like
almost uh White is almost there no I
mean uh
simply uh the next Lab step is just to
uh if the only way you to stop the
advance the check from G4 is let's say
white gold something like Rook C1 uh and
then I would probably place my Bishop in
the center to D5 without giving check
immediately and then all night B5 also
also oh yeah number three
uh it should be over in two moves uh
well you got to be one thing to be
careful of like it's C7 Rook takes C7
here is a draw yeah because this is a
stalemate but creature is obviously
going to see that Rook F1 okay Bishop G4
and it's over
I think he just uh
yeah I don't know what he's going for
but okay it looks like a mouth slip like
he he tried exactly yeah you know he
played Rook C1 and he played Rook F1
yeah but that's maybe I don't know if
the Knight is on E6 now is this is the
position uh I guess it is um no no he
hasn't played Rock F1 that was a bit of
a glitch he's still thinking in this
position but this is essentially
resignable
yeah and Dina by the way she did not
manage to hold that position heroic
effort but she did lose that night in
game we were checked we were checking
out
so she's gonna have to win tomorrow with
the white pieces
and yeah
um black is thinking
but the game is essentially over okay he
made a move
no again it's trying to work off one
I I don't know exactly Let me refresh
let me see if this is actually what
happens
or no Rook C1 Rooks the area Rook C1 is
more like it
yeah okay
and you were saying missile in like yeah
also but also even C7 immediately yeah
C7 yeah also it's not you can do that
too yeah so it's just time to resign
yeah
I guess but
I mean it could be that uh black wants
to sack his uh Rook for
for the you know for the pawn and then
wait for to get mated it happens oh
would you play who would you resign
against if you had a king against bishop
and I like what would be the minimum
rating or would you play a couple of
moves to make sure that you're a minimum
wage
well if the king is uh on the other
corner I would probably play his Blitz
you know some with with uh but yeah
most of the time I don't think it makes
sense but uh
it's okay it's again you can only it's
you can only lose one point you you can
always resign so it depends but
oh and On My Level we we don't uh play
this
yeah there have been a few cases I think
of people struggling but I mean
yeah
everybody learns it at some point so
I always wonder if there's like some GM
who has never learned the technique and
they're just framed that they never get
it
yeah I see yeah maybe he he
he's probably waiting now for let's say
for the check on
C7 and then Kink B7 but even then
somehow makes no sense I mean King D7
and then check on D6 looks like easy you
know
big Korea and ip5 King D7 C7 premium
yeah you have to move move the Rook to
D2 and then
uh let's see you can start with C7 if
you want I guess seven yeah exactly King
B6 and I guess Bishop P2 is an important
resource here actually exactly yeah
and then of course you can uh play Rook
Queen and Rook oh yeah you could play
rookies too but wait does white have to
go
can white get a better no I cannot get a
better version but of course of course
uh I don't think you you you have to
play immediately King uh D7 yeah no you
shouldn't you should you should play
more effectively there should be six I
think it's better to be in to this place
a bit to misplace the you know the rook
and and of course you can first go King
D7 and then check
we've analyzed this very very deeply
yeah I can't see one king D7 but King
d796 as Bishop C4 covers so
uh I mean 27 that only check and then
back and then Bishop C4
yeah the record is just helpless so
let's see record has moved Bishop D5
that's also fine you want to think oh
you want to go c7987
but I guess wait a minute King CA
then C7 there's Rook C6 draw so
oh
oops
you know there's always that's chess
free there's always a possibility to
screw it up
um I'm sure Vaseline you've had it like
you've seen your share of crazy games
that were completely unusable or
undrawable and then
something you know some super tournament
just played a crazy move
uh yeah no no okay I mean especially
um especially Blitz I mean I play linear
in Saint Louis a match and I needed only
a draw to win the match finally and the
last game I was so so panicked that
during several moves I had made in one I
think because I was playing for draw I
was trying to take all his pieces we
eventually uh I succeeded you know but
of course it was much easier to to mate
in one you know yeah yeah when you when
you see like a grand master Miss man and
one it can be very hard to understand
how it's possible from the side but
they're not looking at the position in
the same way they're just like not
seeing it okay so Roxy to C7 and I think
the more the king is also in the in the
right corner for white so this is truly
Elementary it's going to be resigns
[Music]
so
let's Bend food on
no with little time anything anything
can happen in fact
yeah I think the game is over the time
that time has stopped kicking so
I guess he's resigned
yes he has resigned C7 check and Cree
core who travel difficulties not an
obstacle he plays a nice game
and he defeats Samora but okay tomorrow
they still have another game right if he
doesn't lose then he would have a free
day on on day three which is important
you know right and those three days they
they really they help people conserve
energy but that means that day one of
the theater World Cup is officially in
the books we had so many cool matchups
couple of upsets a lot of interesting
games and guess what we basically have
another month of action just like this
as obviously some of the top guns will
only start playing in round two as we
take a quick look at the schedule
um we have game two tomorrow and then
tie break for those matches that require
a tie break on July 14 that that repeats
itself all the way to the final
um and the time will be the same so it's
very straightforward schedule tomorrow
will be game two of these first round
matchups as many many players have to
win in order to tie up the match which
makes these second games very very
interesting vessel in and it's been such
a pleasure compensating what are your
thoughts excellent on day one sort of as
expected or it's something yeah I feel
like we'll be different about this I
liked young guys I mean there are many
many young young new young players which
I don't even know and they're putting a
good fight so uh chefs this is a lot
from what I see there's a lot of talent
you know and uh again
um
of course uh I mean from what I see it
becomes more and more obvious that chess
is about age and Gary actually he yes
this the last couple of days we clearly
saw that even a genius
he he needs practice so all these young
guys that play online every day they
improve very quickly and we see this now
in the World Cup we have many many uh
I mean young Grandmasters and it will be
easy it will be interesting from
from either even the tie breaks uh for
for big favorites are not going to be so
easy
yeah and obviously a lot of the people
in the chat they're like upsets we like
upsets uh they make things really
interesting and we'll definitely have
some of those
um as Vaseline said all these all these
underrated young guys they're gonna be
looking for blood in the rounds to come
and so uh that is basically it for us on
day one
um I just want to thank
um my co-commentators uh it's been an
absolute honor of course how you find
will be joining us again tomorrow for
the first couple of hours and uh vessel
and topolov uh so gracious for for
commentating
um I had such a blast and uh I know
everybody in in the audience did as well
so thank you so much uh Vaseline and you
will be back tomorrow uh we'll have
we'll have the same crew and of course a
big shout out to our production crew
Bigfoot and and everybody else working
incredibly hard behind the scenes to
make the production absolutely seamless
and our jobs easy and of course to the
audience in the chat taking time out of
your Mondays for watching The World's
Cup day two is tomorrow uh starts at the
same time 8 A.M Eastern 5 a.m Pacific
set your calendars that's it for us we
bid you goodbye until tomorrow this was
the fide World Cup 2021 day two tomorrow
goodbye everybody all the best and until
tomorrow tomorrow
foreign
[Music]